So, ahem, da sind wir, wisst ihr was Massive sagt, meine Tastatur ist kaputt, Tastatur
ist kaputt, das sagt extrem, dass meine Tastatur kaputt ist, weil sie lustigerweise jetzt grad
funktioniert, ist aber random ob sie funktioniert oder nicht, jetzt geht sie grad, seht ihr,
ich kann kopieren, aber jetzt ist es wieder kaputt, die Kontrolltaste ist kaputt und zwar
ich hatte ja die hier, ich hatte ja das Teil und ich hab das noch nicht, ich hab das noch,
das ist noch nicht mal ein Jahr alt das Teil, ja, und die erste Taste ist kaputt, also sieht
man mal was für eine Kackqualität der ganze Crap mittlerweile ist, genau so ein Teil ist
das, so ich hab jetzt erstmal eine neue Übergangsweise bestellt und die alte schick ich dann an Logitech,
weil ich glaube es geht los, kann doch nicht sein, dass die Tastatur nach 11 Monaten kaputt
geht, wenn du dir mal diese alten IBM Tastaturen anguckst, die sind irgendwie 50 Jahre alt
und gehen heute noch, kann doch nicht sein, dass die Tastatur nach 11 Monaten kaputt geht,
Pogu riecht Pogu, und wisst ihr was nochmal besonders Pogu ist, ich muss mal die VM anmachen,
nachdem meine Tastatur kaputt ist, ich hab's grad schon mal erzählt, aber ich erzähl's
einfach nochmal, weil ich glaub war eh noch keiner da, ich kann gar nicht richtig tippen,
deswegen machen wir heute ein bisschen RGB Beleuchtung, deswegen hab ich meine Kamera
wieder angeschlossen, Facecam, nein Quatsch keine Facecam, Lötkolbencam und Fingercam,
ja dann ist die Discord benannt, dann warte ich noch mal kurz mit erzählen bis die Benachrichtigung
raus ist, erstmal den ganzen Kram hier zumachen, es ist so scheiße mit der Tastatur die nicht
geht, ich krieg an, you appear to have an internet, ja ja ist gut, machen wir alles zu
hier, alles weg, brauchen wir heute nämlich nicht, alles weg, brauchen wir heute auch nicht,
alles weg, brauchen wir heute alles nicht, so hier machen wir wieder den Endplayer, exellent,
Beleuchtung ist ein bisschen hell, die Beleuchtung ist ein bisschen hell, findet ihr nicht auch?
Finde ich auch, dass die Beleuchtung, wie krieg ich die eigentlich, ich muss da unten
mal diese komische Uhr weg machen, die Beleuchtung ist ein bisschen sehr hell oder, ich mach mal
kurz gucken wie das hier mit ist, ne jetzt ist Beleuchtung ein bisschen dunkel, ich glaub
ich mach mal die, ich mach mal kurz die Farbe ein bisschen anders, ich glaub, ich glaub
so ist besser, ich glaub so ist besser, exellent, oh hier danke für die ganzen Subs, der Scamtrain
ist am Start, poggers wer hat denn hier gesubbt, wie machst du das mit dem Endplayer und deinem
Endplayer, das ist ne App ja, die die Webcam als RTSP Server exportiert, das ist diese
hier, diese App, ist das, die Bedienung von der App ist absolut grauenhaft schlecht, aber
es geht, Quali ist in Ordnung, ja also werden gesubbt, zeig mal her, der Sandor385 hat gesubbt
und zwar 5 Monate in Folge, exellent Sub, ich kann leider nicht so viele Emotes machen,
weil meine Tastatur im Arsch ist, der Vettros hat wieder gesubbt, 7 Monate lang, danke für
den Sub, hast du nicht auch ne G513 Vettros, meine ist heute kaputt gegangen, ich hab jetzt
ne Alsatztastatur bestellt und nach 11 Monaten ist die schon kaputt, topics, 3 Monate, dankeschön
für den Sub, big brain subscription, ja Elgato hat ne App gekauft, Elgato hat die App gekauft,
die haben Epocam oder wie das heißt, gekauft, das funktioniert leider nicht über RTSP,
da musste das Ding per USB anschließen und irgendwie in UBS ne extra Quelle und so, ganz
ehrlich mir ist das so lieber, zumal die Verzögerung ist halt auch nicht groß, ich mein, weiss
ich ob ihr das hört, weiss ich ob ihr das hört im Hintergrund so, ja ich hab wieder
mit der Katze gespielt übrigens hier, exzellent, NDI wäre auch ne Möglichkeit, Gesicht im
Fingernagel gespiegelt, ja null, ja vielleicht, vielleicht, ich mein, was passieren könnte
ist, dass meine Nase oder mein Kopf ab und zu hier mal so ins Bild kommt, wenn man heut
irgendwie mal Lötstells machen, das ist dann hier so auf der Höhe, dass du so ins Bild
rein, mal gucken, sehen wir dann, ja das ist die App hier, mein Tastatur ist so kaputt,
also ich zeige euch mal was wir heute machen, Alter, es ist ätzend mit kaputter Tastatur,
ich bleib jetzt einfach hier unter Linux, scheiß drauf, also ich zeige euch mal kurz
was und zwar, was wir hier am Start haben, ich muss gerade mal umdrehen, ah ich muss
die Forscher auf dem Tablet noch anmachen, sonst seh ich nix, ganz wichtig, Twitch Forscher
auf dem Tablet, weil ich sitz ja mitm Rücken zum Monitor und dann seh ich nix, so, also
ich zeige euch erstmal kurz, was ich heute am Start habe hier an Hardware, während ich
die, äh, mein Twitch Forscher aufmache, Wubblords, wo is er, nicht Wubbl, Wubbl, Wubbls hier, Wubblords,
da is er, so, gegen Schwerbo für Godfall, übelstes Suckergame, ich hab mal ein bisschen
Let's Play angeguckt, das ist mega schlecht, gibt es Updates zum Zimmer Setup, hab ich
noch nie ein Zimmer Setup gemacht, noch nie ein Streaming Setup Video gemacht, so, gut,
also was wir heute am Start haben ist, machs gut Werder, bis denn, also was wir heute am
Start haben ist folgendes, ich hab nämlich ein paar Dinger, wobei ich zeige euch das
am besten in der Kamera, ich hab ein paar Sachen gekauft, unter anderem für Weihnachtsbaum
Beleuchtung, Weihnachtsbeleuchtung an sich und zum Beleuchten vom Bett nachts, da wollte
ich unten, ich wollte am Bett nehmen, entweder unter oder neben am Bett, wollte ich so links
und rechts oder besser vorne und links, also vorne an der Seite, wollte ich LED Streifen
hinmachen, dass ich Licht besser nachts, quasi mit dem Bewegungsbilder, dass ich ein bisschen
gedimmtes Licht anmachen kann nachts, oder auch weil man morgens im Dunkeln aufsteht,
dass es dann so langsam einfadet und so, das ist glaube ich ganz nice, aber heute will
ich erstmal probieren, wie man das allgemein macht, so ich hab mir so einen Strip hier
gekauft, ich kann übrigens gerade meine Tastatur nicht verwenden, weil Control-Taste im Arsch,
WS211 habe ich hier, ich zeige euch auch gleich in der Cam, äh, nein, LED, ja schon besser,
so einen Strip habe ich von, wie heißt die, BFG oder so, Lightning, ne, äh, ach, und
ich hab die, äh, ich hab den 5 Meter, 5 Meter Strip, habe ich das überhaupt richtig
geschrieben? Moment, wie heißen die LEDs? Ich glaube ich hab mich vollschrieben, WS2812B,
WS2812B, ja, ohne LEDs triffst du die zum Boden fallen, genau, das wäre auch eine Porgas-Idee,
hier, IP 30, 5 Meter hab ich, aus irgendwelchen Gründen bin ich nicht in der Lage, hab ich
mich verschrieben, 28, ach, 281, ach, lull, die hier habe ich am Start, genau, 60 Stück,
IP 30, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das ein guter Preis ist, ehrlich gesagt, aber, wird schon
passen, ich glaub bei dem Herstellerabschluss hab ich das auch bestellt, 5 Meter, und, ähm,
als Controller verwenden wir den hier, Leute, ich zeige euch das Zeug auch gleich alles
in der Kamera, nur dass ich mal so ungefähr die Daten gesehen hab, ähm, sind die einzeln
ansprechbar? Ja, sind sie, ne, über diese Frage übersehen sie ich grad, hast du die
Tastatur nicht erst vor kurzem gekauft? Doch, vor genau 11 Monaten, 19. Dezember hab ich
den gekauft letztes Jahr, übelster Crap, dass du schon, hast du schon den neuen ESP32
gesehen? Ja, hab ich, bin ich mal echt gespannt drauf, äh, genau, das mit dem M-Player hab
ich grad schon beantwortet, genau, also das nehmen wir heute mal als Controller, falls
das nicht gescheit funktioniert, dann nehmen wir den ESP32 Node MCU, mal gucken, wie man
das hier macht, mit so einem kleinen, da müssen wir die Pins dran löten, ähm, ne, wir meinen
nicht den 32S, wir meinen den neuen ESP32C3, glaub ich, das soll Nachfolger vom ESP8266
werden, ist aber noch nicht erschienen, das ist echt ätzend mit der Tastatur, ich sag's
euch, bleibt jetzt einfach hier im Linux, so, ich zeig euch mal kurz, was wir am Start
haben als Hardware. Welchen Raspberry Pi würdest du empfehlen? Preis-Leistungs-mäßig
den letzten Dreier, wenn du ein bisschen mehr RAM brauchst, ein bisschen mehr CPU, dann
den Vierer, was anderes lohnt sich nicht. Wie hast du dein Home Office Setup gemacht?
Kann leider nicht über RDP, äh, gar nicht, ich benutze einfach einen extra Browser für
mein Firmenzeug, aber ansonsten geh ich da über so einen Citrix Client von der Arbeit
drauf, oder Citrix, wie spricht man das eigentlich cool aus, wir sind ja hier unter Profis, das
heißt bestimmt nicht Citrix, das heißt bestimmt Citrix oder so, oder Satrix oder Zitrix oder
schön hässig Zitrix, Zitrix oder Chitrix, also Leute, ich zeig euch mal kurz, was wir
am Start haben, also, wir haben aber den Controller am Start, achso ich muss meine Vorschau, ich
muss meine, ich hab übrigens das Setup immer noch nicht großartig verbessert, ich hab immer
noch keine Live Vorschau, jetzt krieg ich wieder gottvoll Werbung, ey, muss ich mal
kurz warten bis der Kram vorbei ist, ich seh immer noch keine Live Vorschau von der Kamera,
das ist ein bisschen, bisschen sucked, KiteRakes, KiteRakes, so ist es jetzt mal fertig, nein,
immer noch, immer noch hier, kack Werbung, also, so ist die Werbung heute irgendwann
durch, ja, exellent, ok, ja also, ähm, ich brauch unbedingt noch ne Live Vorschau hier
irgendwo auf dem Tablet, ansonsten sackt das ziemlich, ich, ich leak mich, ja hier guck
mal, Leak hier, Massive Leak in der, in der Tüte und so, ja, das ist ein Fire HD, das
ist das billigste Fire HD aller Zeiten, ja, so, also, Leute, ähm, also was wir am Start
haben ist, erstens mal haben wir hier, ich mach mal kurz den Lötkolbenstückchen weg
hier oben, zack, bis ich Platz hab, also, als erstes haben wir den hier am Start als
Controller, ich pack den mal kurz aus, oh Moment, ich hab hier noch mal ein Sound an
auf dem Tablet, das ist natürlich nicht so ein Zweck der Übung, äh, warte mal, wo
ist der Knopf hier da, als Maul, die Schalte, so, ich pack das mal kurz aus, das ist ein
besonders kleiner ESP32, eigentlich die Verpackung und alles ist echt nice gemacht hier, also,
ähm, die bringen hier ein Pinlayout mit, wo man gucken kann, was Sache ist, jetzt gucken,
dass ich ein bisschen näher ranrücken kann, dann wackelt es auch nicht so, ich muss irgendwie
gucken, dass ich mein, mach mal so, dass ich mein Arm auflegen kann, ähm, genau, also
sprich, man hat hier ein Pinlayout und alles mögliche dabei, ist zumindest ganz nützlich,
dass das dabei liegt, da sieht man nochmal die Specs von dem Ding, ähm, da sieht man
auch, dass dieses kleine Kackding hier, also ihr seht, guck mal hier, das ist mein Finger,
also ihr seht, das ist doch, also, ist schon recht klein, ja, das Teil, ähm, und da drauf
ist ein 32 Bit Dual Core, also ein ganz normaler ESP32, 32 Bit Dual Core, ähm, 2,4 GHz Wi-Fi,
ich bin ja mal gespannt, wann die Chinesen ein, ähm, Ding rausbringen mit 5 GHz Wi-Fi,
dann hast du 4 MB Flash und 4 MB RAM, was beides ziemlich viel ist, ähm, du hast eine
USB-LED-Onboard, die werden wir ja nicht brauchen, das da oben ist übrigens die WLAN-Antenne
da, ja, USB-Serial, direkt, was auch cool ist, direkter Anschluss für Batterie, ähm, ultra
low power im Standby, das ist ziemlich, der braucht wirklich wenig, der braucht irgendwie
10 micro Ampere, also sehr wenig, ähm, genau, du hast halt nur 14 GPIOs, wenn man sich hier
mal so ein, ähm, wo hab ich's hier, wenn man sich mal so ein NodeMCU anguckt, der hat
ein bisschen mehr Pins, ja, ist aber auch, ist aber auch eine ganze Ecke fetter, und
ich hab hier irgendwie so ein Silikonband, das ist ganz nice, ich weiß grad nicht, wo
ich's hin hab, da kann ich am Ende einfach den Gramm einmal Silikonband drum herum wickeln
und gut ist, also, das ist der Controller, da müssen wir jetzt hier die, die Pins dran
löten, den anderen Grämpel brauchen wir nicht, jetzt mach ich natürlich Low-Prain und hab
schon die Verpackung weggeschmissen, wo hab ich die, ah, hier hab ich schon mit dem Fuß
wieder herstelzen, die Verpackung, so, also wollen wir den Gramm mal wieder rein, brauchen
wir nicht, das Batterieanschluss und so ist auch alles dabei, also richtig neisse Verpackung,
und jetzt kann ich's wegschmeißen, jetzt zeig ich euch mal was wir für LEDs nehmen,
zwar die da, das ist so die Standard, mit die Standard-Strips schlechthin, ja, WS2812B,
kostet ungefähr 45 oder 30, zwischen 35-45 Euro, das Vera Toolkit hab ich auch am Start,
allerdings grad nicht hier liegen sollen, nur den Schraubendreher zu, das ist so einer
der absoluten Standard-Strips, die gehen eigentlich mit allem, ja, also da gibt's, da gibt's eigentlich
fast nicht, fast nix mit dem das nicht funktioniert, ich pack das mal aus, die kommen eigentlich
auch ganz nett verpackt daher, also sprich, die kommen auf so einer, auf so einer Rolle
und ich bin ein bisschen ein Noob was LED-Strips angeht, also sprich, hier, hier sieht man
die, die LEDs, und ich bin ein bisschen Noob was LEDs angeht, deswegen ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher wie man das anschließen muss, ich vermute mal, dass man, hier in das rote
kommt plus, in das weiße kommt ground und in das grüne kommt der Datenpin oder so rein,
denk ich mal, das hier dürfte wahrscheinlich plus und minus für den Strom sein, wenn man
das direkt ans Netzteil anschließen will oder so, was wir hier auch machen, also wir
schließen den nicht am ESP an, der glüht uns, brennt uns ja durch, so, genau, das sind
die LEDs, lege mal die mal neben hin, so, dann habe ich noch ein paar Kabels zum reinstecken,
brauchen wir bestimmt, die üblichen Jumper, Jumper-Kabels, wofür wird die LED-Leiste
am Ende benutzt, also aktuell will ich gerade überlegen, ob ich irgendwie mit einer solcher
Leiste, vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit der, weil die ist weiß und die ist, mal gucken,
mal gucken, einmal was für einen Weihnachtsbaum, ich meine, das ist eine 5 Meter-Leiste, 5
Meter, das ist schon ordentlich, für einen Weihnachtsbaum oder für Weihnachtsbeleuchtung,
in Zukunft will ich die für mein Bett verwenden, ich will das quasi unten und an der Seite
vom Bett dran machen, dass ich das nachts mit dem Bewegungsmelder quasi einfaden lassen
kann, so, und ich will jetzt aber erstmal ausprobieren, ob es denn überhaupt, überhaupt
ordentlich funktioniert, ja, wie viele LEDs pro Meter, der hat, ich habe jetzt die, ich
kann es dir sagen, ich wollte es dir eigentlich auf der, auf der Verpackung zeigen, wenn ich
jetzt wüsste, wo ich die Verpackung hingehauen habe, ich habe die gerade in hohem Bogen irgendwo,
weggeschmissen, egal, dann sag ich es dir, der hat 60, der hat 60 LEDs pro Meter, die
Dinger gibt's, die Dinger gibt's in 30 LEDs pro Meter, 60 LEDs pro Meter oder 144 LED,
ach ja, und das ist 5 Volt, das heißt, es kann sein, dass das nicht 5 Meter geht und
das wird vielleicht noch hinten, ich meine, es sollte wahrscheinlich reichen, wenn ich
vorne und hinten Strom anschließe, denke ich mal, werden wir sehen, ich werde es dann,
also wenn wir den Controller geflasht haben und das angeschlossen haben und es funktioniert,
dann werde ich das Ding hier mal ein bisschen auf dem, ich sag immer noch übelst das Geddo
Setup hier mit dem Tisch am Start, ich brauch mal ein bisschen was stabileres, ihr habt
den Vorteil, ihr habt den Vorteil, es wackelt jetzt, aber ihr seht nicht, dass es wackelt,
weil das Handy mit wackelt, das ist eigentlich lustig, ihr seht nur, dass es wackelt, weil
Dinge auf dem Tisch wackeln, aber ihr seht die Kamera nicht wackeln, was eigentlich
echt lustig ist, weil hier, das wackelt total das Ding, aber ihr seht es nicht, tja, genau,
also mit Voltage, ich hab da nicht so großartige Erfahrungen, aber ich hab schon einmal für
letzten Weihnachten, ne, ne, der Data Pin braucht wahrscheinlich nur 3,3 und wenn es
kurz ist, reicht das, ja, ja, ja, ich hab schon mal so einen ähnlichen Strip, allerdings
in so, wie so diese normalen Lichterketten für Weihnachtsbaum aussehen, letztes Jahr
ja schon mal gemacht und das ging auch gut, da hab ich auch einfach Strom an Eingang und
dann Ausgang dran und dann war gut, mal schauen, ob das, ob das klappt, so, achja und als Netzteil
hab ich was ordentliches am Start, ich hab hier einen, weiß ich, ob man das gut erkennt,
ich versuch es mal in die Kamera zu halten, ich hab hier ein recht starkes Netzteil, was
für das Ding ausreichen würde und zwar, das hat, wenn ich jetzt ne Vorschau hätte, könnte
ich sehen, ob man es erkennt, das hat, wo steht es denn, sollte 10 Ampere haben, ich seh
es halt hier, ich weiß nicht, ob man es erkennt, aber hier steht es, 5 Volt, 10 Ampere, sprich
maximal 50 Watt, das soll so halbwegs reichen für den Stick, denk ich mal, äh, ich hab
auch noch einen zweiten Stick bestellt, äh, kein Stick, was war, aber ich den zweiten
Strip, ich wollte, chat, ich wollte übrigens in Titel, wollte ich, äh, RGB LED Strip schreiben
und dann hat Twitch gesagt, nein, du darfst nicht Strip in Titel schreiben, weil, ähm,
es verstößt gegen die, gegen die Rechte, gegen die Guidelines, Monka Toss, Strip, Strip
ist verboten im Titel, das geht nicht, da war schon der Twitch Support, ist schon gekreist
über mir, ja, naja, ähm, genau, Rahmen ausblenden, wir stripen nur ein paar Kabel und machen LED
Strips, ja, ich muss unbedingt unten die, die Uhrzeit ausblenden, wobei, ganz ehrlich
mal, ich glaub euch, euch stört die Uhrzeit, hier unten, da, da ist ne Uhrzeit, da, glaub
euch stört das gar nicht so großartig, aber mich triggert das voll, das da ne, da ist
sie, mit Uhrzeit und so, null wie, naja, wofür ist die LED Leiste, naja, ich will jetzt
erst mal kurz gucken, ob der Kram gut funktioniert, ich werd damit vielleicht ein bisschen Weihnachtsbeleuchtung
oder Christbaumbeleuchtung oder so bauen, ähm, und Ziel ist eigentlich, dass ich was für
mein Bett hab, das kommt dann unten, das kommt dann hier unten und an der Seite ans Bett ran,
und, ähm, dann mach ich noch nen Bewegungsmelder in mein Schlafzimmer und wenn ich nachts aufstehe,
dann fade das so ein, so, der LED Strip, der fade dann auf, auf, auf orange, gelb fade
das so ein, wenn ich mich dann ins Bett liege und dann das wieder erkennt, fade das wieder
aus, das wär so die Premium Variante, ja, ich weiß First World Problems, aber besser
haben als brauchen. Also Delay dürften wir hier eigentlich nicht großartig haben, naja,
die Uhrzeit ist nicht so wahnsinnig genau, würd ich sagen, da unten 50, ja, die Uhrzeit
ist da unten schneller als meine Windows-Uhr auf der anderen Seite, also wirklich großartig
Sachen sünden kann man da nicht dran, ja, gut, so, ich guck mal kurz durch, ob ich irgendwelche
Questions übersehen hab, also wie gesagt, wir machen das mit WLED, das kann man auch
wunderbar in Home Assistant einbinden, ups, jetzt soll ich mal die Dinger wegmachen, exellent,
so, hab ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen, oh doch, wenn ich hier drauf hab, dann wackelt's,
so lustig, wenn ich hier so wackel dran, es fällt kaum auf, dass es wackellos ist, dabei
schwankt der ganze Tisch voll, ja, also zeig mal her, hab ich was übersehen im Chat, das
Netzteil wird knapp, ja, müssen wir mal gucken, aber wir benutzen WLED und damit kann man hab
ich gesehen, kann man auch ein bisschen den Output reduzieren, dass es dann noch passt,
aber wie gesagt, hier haben wir kein Delay, also ich sehs ja bei mir im Stream, ich mach
hin, das ist instant, also passt mal auf hier, ich halt euch jetzt mal dran, ihr sehts mal
mit dem Klatschen, also wenn ich hier so mach jetzt, da ist kein Delay, vielleicht 200-300
Millisekunden, wenns hochkommt, aber, also für das, dass das quasi vom iPhone übers WLAN
und dann hier gestreamt wird und so ist das eigentlich ganz ok, für alles andere, das
könnt ihr euch jetzt selber übelst aufrüsten, so, also Chat, fangen wir mal an, macht es
Sinn das Bild zu drehen, dass wir alle aus deiner Perspektive sehen, hm, wollen wir das
probieren, wollen wir mal gucken, wie das aussieht mit gedrehtem Bild, wollen wir das mal ausprobieren,
können wir machen, wir könnens ja mal ausprobieren, schadet nix, ich hab übrigens immer noch
so einen kacke Motor drüber, ne, wir probieren, wir drehen das mal, sieht wegen dem Tilt komisch
aus, ja das kann sein, hm, ich habs ein bisschen stärker getiltet als das letzte Mal, dass
man mehr hier vorne sieht, ich bräuchte eigentlich, bräuchte ich noch, ich mein ich hab ja ein
Stativ, aber ich müsste irgendwie mal gucken, dass ich das Handy da dran krieg, dass es
direkt von oben drauf, draufdingsen kann, ja, aber wir probieren es mal, wir probieren das
mal mit, äh, wie macht man das, M-Player-Flip, das geht, die M-Player kann das nicht, ah,
VF-Mirror, ok, probieren wir mal aus, wie das jetzt ausschaut, äh, nein, nein chat, nein,
das wollen wir nicht, das sieht, das sieht falsch rum aus, das ist gespiegelt,
Rotate, dann das M-Player, das Rotate 4, what the fuck, das geht,
ist das jetzt, ist das jetzt Rotated, ne oder, da ist nichts Rotated, wobei, Leute, wie soll
ich das überhaupt rotieren, ich mein, äh, Hochkant geht nicht und so dann steht die
Uhrzeit auf dem Kopf, das ist auch Mist, ne ich muss das eigentlich so lassen, anders
kann ich das nicht mehr großartig, großartig machen, ne, das funktioniert nicht, ne, ich
muss, ich muss einfach mein Stativ irgendwie anders und ich muss mal ein Stativ holen,
aktuell hab ich das an so einem, an so einem Anschraubding, wo auch meine Lupe dran ist
zu blöden, da werden wir jetzt erstmal mit leben müssen, ja, mal gucken, wie man das
Rotaten kann mit FFmpeg, oh Rotate, Alter, ok, wir können es mit FFmpeg machen und gucken,
wir gucken mal, wie es aussieht, wir gucken mal, wie es aussieht mit FFplay, FFplay, und
dann muss man was machen, minus VF, VF, äh, nein, nein, was brauchen wir, 2, 0, äh,
3, gleich müssen wir sie haben, hä, what the fuck, was, hä, das, das, das übersteigt
jetzt mein Brain, was da der Unterschied dazwischen ist, warum kann der nur 90° rotieren, will
der mich verabbeln, was ist das denn, hot, HF, HF, ja, das kann sein, ja, wahrscheinlich
ist das HF, ne, ja, wir wollen es ja nicht, wir wollen es ja nicht, wir wollen es ja nicht
flippen, oder, ne, was muss man machen, transpose, halfflip, wie ist HDF, das ist jetzt einmal
falsch rum, ok, ich, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es so schwierig ist in einem Video, einfach
1880° zu rotieren, ich kann es nicht unbedingt, ich kann das nicht gescheit mit OBS machen,
was, transpose, transpose, what the fuck, ok, da wäre ich jetzt im Leben nicht drauf
gekommen, dass das funktioniert, also was zum, what the, Leute, da wird es mir schlecht,
wenn ich mir das angucke, da kommt es mir voll vor, als steht man auf dem Kopf, also
ich würde nicht sagen, dass es besser ist, ich, ne, ne, da wird es mir schlecht, kriege
ich, kriege ich, ne, ja, ich weiß nicht, nicht motion sickness, weißt du was, wir machen
jetzt FFplay, wir fangen jetzt an mal den Kram zu löten, wegen dem Tilt wahrscheinlich,
so, also, legen wir mal los, ich glaube, wenn ich da drin rumwurste, dann ist er auch halb
zu wild, ok, also, wie gesagt, ich habe hier Netzteil am Start, 50W, 5V, 10A, mal gucken,
es sollte, sollte reichen, hoffe ich, man mag, also ich meine, die schreiben 90W Verbrauch,
aber ich weiß ja nicht, das Ding, das, das, das glüht ja nicht, also, gucken wir mal,
ich leg das hier mal neben hin, das Netzteil, das hier legen wir auch mal irgendwo da hinten
hin, das, die Kabels machen wir auch mal weg, jetzt löten wir mal diesen Kram hier dran,
ich überleg grad, wie man das am besten dran kriegt, ich hab hier auch nicht so ultra viel
Platz, also, schauen wir mal, wie man das am besten dran, oh, Monarch S, das, das Wlan
ist ziemlich, ziemlich Monka S, Monka Essig, also hier, das, das fällt gleich ab, das Wlan
links oben, da muss ich aufpassen, vielleicht krieg ich das wieder, ich, ich mach lieber
nichts dran, ich mach, ich mach lieber nichts dran, so, also, wie machen wir das am besten
dran, machen wir den Kram, machen wir den so rum, oder machen wir den Kram so rum, ich
würd sagen, wir machen es so rum, ich würd sagen, wir machen so, ich würd sagen, wir
machen so, da ist der ganze Kram oben, kann ich dann später einfach irgendwas drum wickeln
und dann ist zu, ja, mir gehts auch voll Monka S, also, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, wie
wir das gescheit dran kriegen, so, ich mach mal an, zack, übrigens, die Steckdosenleiste
hier, das ist die, die ich mir kaufen musste, weil der Chet gesagt hat, ich muss mir die
kaufen, weil sie Saps gegiftet haben, und die hab ich vorhin geflasht und die funktioniert,
man kann die noch flaschen, exellent, Gosund, war das, Gosund, Gosund mit drei Stecker und
dreimal USB, so, mal kurz hier gucken, dass das kabelt ein bisschen, da rum geht, ich hab
wie gesagt echt, nee, all zu viel, nicht all zu viel Platz, so, schauen wir mal, also,
sind wir überhaupt schon warm, ja, exellent, ist warm, so, mal gucken, dass man das jetzt
gerade dran, oh, nee, das ist schon mal schepp, das sackt, das müssen wir grad machen, das
triggert mich immer, wenn sowas schepp ist, ja, das ist jetzt schön grad, so ist das gut,
so mach ich das, exellent, so, dann machen wir hier, man macht meistens auf der eine
Seite ein, dann auf der anderen Seite ein, und dann ist das schön fest und kann nix
mehr passieren, ja, hat mal einer von euch schon mal diese Pins zum Stecken ausprobiert,
ob die was taugen, es gibt so, es gibt so Pins, die steckt man einfach nur rein und
die bleiben dann von alleine dran, die muss man nicht festlöten, das ist immer noch der
Lowboblötkorb, was ist denn ein Lowboblötkorb, naja, je nachdem wie low das ist, ich mein,
die Station kostet 150 Euro und ist eigentlich ziemlich gut, also ich würd nicht sagen,
dass das ein Lowboblötkolben ist, wieviel Grad, der steht aktuell auf 360, ich hab da
auch noch zwei Spitzen für, ein bisschen kleinere und ne ganz kleine, die werden hier
vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, aber ich weiß nicht, wo sie sind, nein, nein, nein,
das ist nicht der USB-Lötkolben, null, das ist nicht der USB-Lötkolben, nein, nein,
der USB-Lötkolben, der braucht hier eine halbe Stunde, bis das dran ist, ich mein,
so easy, wie das hier mit dem da dran geht, geht das mit dem USB-Lötkolben nicht, ne,
das ist nicht der USB-Lötkolben, naja, exellent, so, aber den dran dran, gibt es, was, es gibt
doch Power Delivery, was, was ist denn ein Power Delivery USB-Lötkolben, das ist bleihaltiges,
ja, ich weiß, ich hab jetzt schon öfters gehört, dass man das im Profi-Bereich und
so nicht mal verwenden darf, aber im Heim-Bereich ist das vollkommen okay, das fließt, das
fließt auch viel besser und schmilzt schneller und es ist viel einfacher, sind 360 nicht
ein bisschen viel, wahrscheinlich schon, aber juckt mich nicht, so, schön grad, ich könnte
ja gucken, ob ich die, ob ich die WLAN-Antenne wieder richtig dran gelötet guck, aber ich
hab Schiss, dass ich die komplett abmache und dann kommen wir nicht ins WLAN, ich muss
eh mal gucken, was wir für ein WLAN verwenden, weil ich weiß mein WLAN-Passwort nicht auswendig,
so, schauen wir mal, so, machen wir den hier noch mal schnell dran, also je nachdem, wie
gut das klappt, wird der Stream wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht ewig gehen, so schauen wir
mal, was ich das grad gemacht hab, hey, guckt mal hier, first try poggers, exellent, was,
das ist das Schnell-Ladezeug von Apple, ah du meinst diese quick, diese Apple Quick-Charge-Gedönster,
ja sag mal so der USB-Lötkolben, den ich mir gekauft hab, das ist ja so ein 6 Euro USB-Lötkolben,
also das ist ja nicht der hier, wie gesagt, der hier ist der, der zu dieser Station, zeig
euch mal das Ding kurz, wartet mal, ähm, der zu dieser Station hier gehört, hier, da kannst
du hier die Temperatur einstellen, ob man hier was erkennt, da kannst du die Tastatur,
äh, Tastatur, da kannst du, im Moment da ist der Chat, direkt der Chat davor, Alter,
ich muss das mal so machen, stopp, jetzt müssen wir es ganz gut erkennen, genau, da kannst
du die Tastatur, was hab ich mit der Tastatur, Alter, mein Tastatur ist kaputt, ja, frag
mich nicht, wie ich auf Tastatur die ganze Zeit komm, da muss ich ja mal jetzt sagen
hier, Keg Weight, genau, da kannst du hier einstellen, Temperatur, und man kann hier
hinten irgendwo, gut hier kann man einen ausschalten, hier irgendwo an der Seite, da hab ich noch
nie verwendet, da kann man eine Micro SD reinmachen mit irgendwelchen vorgefertigten, wahrscheinlich
Temperaturstufen oder so, wozu auch immer mal ein Micro SD Kartenleser im Lötkolben
braucht, ich weiß es beim besten Willen nicht, hab ich noch nie verwendet, keine Ahnung,
das Ding kann ich empfehlen, das ist eine Erza Icon Nano, müsst ihr mal gucken, wenn
es die im Angebot gibt, dann kriegt man die vielleicht auch für unter 150 Euro, das müssen
wir mal gucken, ah, der hier, da muss ich, da muss ich gerade noch mal ein bisschen was
dran machen, der ist ein bisschen wenig, kannst du mal schmelzen, Alter, habt ihr schon das
neue Video vom Friseur gesehen, ich hab es mir gestern angeguckt, übelst geil, das alte
Zeug, übrigens, ich mach das auch nicht korrekt, zumindest hat es mein Lehrer damals so gesagt,
ja ich hab echt Glück gehabt, wir hatten so einen Kurs in der Schule für so Lötkram,
das hab ich damals belegt, war eines der wenigen sinnvollen Sachen in der Schule, und zwar
hat mein Lehrer immer gesagt, dass man das Lötzinn nicht an den Kolben schiebt, also
an den Lötkolben, ich rede nicht von Gachibas, sondern das was man löten will heiß macht
und das dann das Lötzinn schmilzt und das dann besser fließt, aber das dauert mir zu
lange, deswegen, fuck, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das geht, wusste gar nicht, dass man
ein Lötzinn festlöten kann, so, ich würde sagen, der
das hätte mir, zeige ich mal her, sieht als ob es hier heiß ist ja noch, das ganze Ding,
das sieht doch recht ordentlich aus, das ist okay, was sagt der Chat, welche Note gibt's,
exzellent, exquisite, ist schon okay, kann man so lassen, denke ich, so, ähm, dann machen
wir mal aus, kurz hier, den heißen Kolben aus, schieben den hier mal hoch, zu unscharf,
okay, echt, ich hab's auf meinem Tablet doch sogar erkannt, der hat nicht richtig scharf
gestellt, ja, naja, so, jetzt haben wir das hier dran, jetzt müssen wir die Firmware
drauf flaschen, das heißt, ich geh jetzt mal zurück ans Linux, stöpsel das Ding an und
wir flaschen, du hast brutalen Delay, also, wie gesagt, bei mir ist das alles top-synced,
so, ich schließe das Ding jetzt mal USB an den Rechner an und dann flaschen wir ihn,
wenn ich einen USB-Kabel hier hab, da, USB-Kabel, exzellent, gucken ob ich hier ESP-Tool installiert
hab, den, das schieben wir mal auf 4 und hier, wenn ich mal meine scheiß Tastatur, Kontrolltaste
drücken könnte, ähm, brauchen wir ESP-Tool, haben wir ESP-Tool installiert, ja, aber du
hast keine Verzögerung im Stream zwischen dem, was ich sage und meiner Kamera, weil das
kannst du nicht haben, ich sehe hier nämlich, dass das einfach exakt zu dem Moment kommt
auf dem Bildschirm, wenn ich auch meine Hand ins Bild stecke, also Sprache und das was
ich mache, müsste schon noch gesynced sein bei dir, so, also ESP-Tool, jetzt müssen
wir erstmal WLED runterladen, das WLED, WLED ist das was ich drauf machen will für die
Chatgeschichte, ja der Chat hat auch bei mir Delay, das ist normal, dass der Chat ein bisschen
Delay hat ist normal, danach könnt ihr euch nicht richten, also, bis der den Chat ausgelesen
hat, den Chat zu euch geschickt hat, äh, nicht zu euch in Stream gemacht hat, den Stream
zu euch geschickt hat, es braucht so 4-5 Sekunden, das hab ich auch, das hab ich aber auch,
also der Rusty, der hat ja auch gerade im Chat schon geschrieben, hab ich in der Vorschau
gesehen, das war dann irgendwie auch 5 Sekunden später erst im Chat, so, ähm, das Ding werden
wir verwenden für Steuerung von LEDs, da müssen wir jetzt erstmal die Firmware runter,
das ist richtig geiles Projekt, geht mit jedem ESP32, und man hat so ein schönes Webinterface
um Zeug einzustellen für die LEDs, so, das heißt wir flashen das jetzt erstmal auf den
ESP, dazu laden wir die neueste Firmware runter, hier, die LED0102 ESP32, spinn, und nun müssen
wir mal gucken, die haben nämlich einen Wiki, wo drin steht, wie man das anschließen muss
bzw. welche Pins man verwenden muss, flashen, alter, flashen, passion, alter, passion war
das, gut, also was, was wollen die hier von mir, Power Supply, ESP Level Shifter, so
gedönst, damit geben wir uns das gar nicht ab, auch hier einen, äh, wie heißt es auf
Deutsch, Capacitor, äh, äh, äh, Kondensator, draufgeschissen, brauchen wir alles nicht,
im Zweifelsfall geht uns der Strip kaputt, brauchen wir alles nicht, so, ähm, irgendwelche
Widerstände dazwischen, das ist auch hier, wer macht das, wir schließen das direkt an,
YOLO, und im Zweifelsfall freut sich der Chat, weil er Smokersmoke macht, so, ähm, die
Wiki Seite ist übrigens nicht so ganz korrekt, SK6812 sind auch 5 Volt, und, äh, 2812 sind
glaube ich 12 Volt, allerdings 2812B sind 5 Volt, naja, also welche Pins brauchen wir
denn, Connect, GPIO2, GPIO2, also sprich, GPIO2 müsste, müsste man mal gucken, GPIO2, wo
ist GPIO2, ah, GPIO2 ist hier gerade drauf, kann man das ummappen, ich hoffe man kann
das ummappen, sonst haben wir ein Problem, GPIO2 ist nicht draußen, ok, ähm, im Zweifelsfall
nehmen wir eine NodeMCU, kein Problem, ja, ja, weil hier guckt mal, guckt mal hier, Pinlayout,
GPIO, 33, 32, 22, 22, 05, 4 Hammer zu bieten, GPIO4, vielleicht gibt es aber auch eine
Firmware, die standardmäßig 4 trennt, ich, ach guck mal hier, GPIO2, was ist denn, was
ist denn APA102, was möchte der uns sagen, was ist APA102, vorher ich den Controller
hab, den hab ich bestellt beim Hersteller, die sind ein bisschen teurer als die AliExpress
NodeMCUs, NodeMCU kriegst du ja für 3,50 Euro, der hier kostet ein bisschen unnütz
mehr, dafür ist er schon klein, ähm, was ist APA102, ich hab keine Ahnung, was der,
was mir das sagen soll, da ist GPIO2 drauf, was ist APA102, das ist für die LED, das
ist die eingebaute LED, geh ich mal von aus, intern, GPIO2 ist die eingebaute LED, ähm,
deswegen müssen wir mal gucken, ob es vielleicht eine Firmware gibt, wo das, ähm, die Auflösung
ist nicht gut genug, dass man das erkennt, oder, ah, das sackt, soll ich mal gucken,
ob ich mal die Auflösung höher stellen kann, dass ihr mehr seht, ich probier das mal kurz,
ich probier mal kurz die Auflösung hoch zu stellen, probier mal mal klar aus, ich stell
mal kurz die Auflösung hoch, ich stell mal kurz, äh, 6 neu starten, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, so, mal gucken, ob die Auflösung jetzt besser ist, ist das jetzt?
1024. Oh guck mal ich glaube man sieht was. Guck mal poggers man sieht was
Exzellent und wie ist das Delay? Ah immer noch gut
Ich habe jetzt 1080p eingestellt als Auflösung. Viel besser oder?
Viel besser
Man kann jetzt richtig was erkennen
Zwar nicht gut, aber wenn ich jetzt sag hier guck mal pins
Jetzt erkennt man da auch was
Ja jetzt erkennt man da auch was und wenn ich sag hier wie sieht das gelötete aus jetzt erkennt man da auch was
Guck mal
Ja ja ja exzellent
Okay
Die WLAN-Antenne ist ein bisschen mitgenommen hier
Das ist Manjaro mit I3 WM
Okay
Das ESP-Tool haben wir installiert also 1- exquisite-Chat
Genau also wir brauchen GPIO 2 das ist schon mal fail, weil den haben wir nicht. Gibt es da irgendeine Firmware wo das nicht
GPIO 2 ist. Wie gesagt wenn alle Stricke reißen nehme ich eine NodeMCU oder vielleicht kann man es im Webinterface einstellen
Das ist M-Player
Also es gibt ESP32-Spin und ESP
LED-Pin 16. Ah guck mal es gibt noch was mit LED-Pin 16 vielleicht sollten wir das verwenden
Lass mal kurz ins wiki gucken
Haben wir da irgendwo eine Beschreibung? Ah hier guckt mal hier steht was was ist
Custom-Build vor ESP LED-Pin ist changed
Das könnte man nehmen dann ist nämlich der LED-Pin 16. Haben wir Pin 16 denn am Controller?
Haben wir hier haben wir Pin 16 am Controller
zur Verfügung
Wartet mal haben wir hier Pin 16
14, 15, 16 ok da flashen wir jetzt erstmal die offizielle Firmware drauf und gucken ob wir den Pin im Webinterface ändern kann
Wenn man den Pin im Webinterface ändern kann ist es easy as fuck dann nehmen wir die defaulten Firmware
Wenn es nicht geht. Ah Moment Moment Moment das ist GPIO. Ich hab mich verguckt
Oh nee, GPIO 16 gibt es auch nicht. Fuck
Gibt GPIO 25, 26, 27, 25, 15, 14, 4, 35, 34, 33, 32, 31. Alter das kann ja nicht euer Ernst sein
Scheiße Alter warum
Ok wir probieren es jetzt aus und gucken ob wir das im Webinterface vielleicht ändern können. Sackt
Ich hab keinen Bock den Grams zu compilen. Vielleicht kann man das im Webinterface ändern. Wir flashen wir flashen das Ding jetzt erst mal
Erst mal Flash Reno. So ESP-Tool wie flasht man den ganzen Krempel die haben doch irgendwie so ein
ESP-Load, das da
Man kann das bestimmt ummappen im Webinterface denke ich mal
So
WLED. Ich muss jetzt den Controller anschließen. Ups
Komm her. Wie gesagt zur Not nehmen wir NodeMCU. Ich hab ja noch eine NodeMCU hier liegen die ist auch schon
Fix und fertig geflasht und alles also
Poggers
Wat
What the hell
Häh? Warum nicht?
Verarschen? Ding im Arsch oder was?
Hä? Ok Moment wir müssen bestimmt wir müssen bestimmt von Hand nen Port angeben
Wo hat er es wo hat er es erkannt?
Def USB
Wo hat er den Controller erkannt?
Doch doch er hat es erkannt hier
Hat er den Controller nicht erkannt? Was ist denn das?
Ich hab den doch schon ich hab den doch schon selbst geflasht hier drauf
What the fuck
Ich hab's geflasht hier drauf
Ja besser doch wow
Warte mal
Ausmachen noch mal kurz
Und dann noch mal ran machen. Das muss gehen
Habt ihr noch hier sogar schon selbst geflasht? Der erkennt ihn doch auch hier
Ist das vielleicht Def?
Def
Wie ist das?
S0 vielleicht
Das ist eine gute Idee
Aber
Ich krieg das USB-Kabel nicht mehr aus dem Controller an
Da müsste doch jetzt eigentlich dastehen was das für ein Device ist normalerweise
Aber steht nicht da
Normalerweise müsste dann dastehen dass das Def, TTY, sonst was ist
Wisst ihr was ich mach das mal ich mach das mal kurz als Route
Ich mach das mal kurz als Route
Home
Max download W-LED
Wie geht man
Wie gibt man bei ESP-Tool? ESP-Tool, Specify, Device. Nein, ich habe kein Oszilloskop.
Hier, minusminus, kommt minusminus, Port.
Hm, wie konnte man jetzt noch mal nachgucken? Ja, uBlock ist, die liefern
sich gerade in Wettstreit mit, äh, wer das sagen hat. Wir gucken mal, wir machen jetzt mal
Platform.io auf. Wir haben noch irgendwo ein Platform.io Projekt. Open. Und da steht
doch immer, ja, Open. Exzellent, das da. Wollen wir jetzt, genau das müssen wir jetzt öffnen.
Wow, alles ja gut hier. Nein, nein, he lacks critical information.
Ich habe ein Scheiß reingeschrieben, aber, ähm, Syria. Hä? Was ist mit meiner Konsole aus? Aus
irgendwelchen Gründen erkennt der den Port nicht. Okay Leute, ich verwende mal ein anderes USB-Kabel.
Ich verwende mal kurz ein anderes USB-Kabel. Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, dass, äh,
USB-Kabel, China-USB-Kabel ist im Arsch. Das China, das China-USB-Kabel. Machen wir schon mal ein anderes USB-Kabel.
Anderes USB-Kabel.
Mal gucken, ob das besser funktioniert. Ja, aber das ist vielleicht gar so billig.
Wisst ihr was? Bam. Reboot. Gucken, vielleicht ist das ja wie unter Windows. Mal schauen.
Wir haben, wir haben auf diesem Board, glaube ich, im Stream sogar schon was gemacht.
Meine E3-Config, die gibt es zum Teil auf GitHub. Mal gucken, irgendwo, ich habe irgendwo ein
Dot-Files-Repo. Das ist nahezu die aktuelle. So. Ups. Passwort. Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Zack. Geh' auf. Alter, mein Tastatur. ESP-Tool. Äh, ja. Ha! Easy. Reboot funktioniert. Sehen wir fast wie unter Windows.
Tja, so einfach kann es sein. Wenn ihr zugucken wollt, wie es flasht. M-Player. Ich hoffe,
das USB-Kabel reicht. Ja. Nein, das USB-Kabel reicht nicht. Ihr könnt nicht zugucken, wie es flasht.
Ex, exzellente, äh, Flash-Geschwindigkeit hier. Wollte mir nur Arbeit sparen. Na, aber so was spart man meistens keine Arbeit.
Man fängt dann an zu customisern und dann hört man eigentlich erst wieder, irgendwie gefühlt zwei Wochen später auf.
Wenn überhaupt. Eigentlich hört man nie auf. Vermutlich Kernel-Modul-Update. Ja, das kann sein, dass ich geupdatet habe, aber nicht neu gestartet.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein, ja. So. Sehr gut. Jetzt haben wir geflashed. Jetzt muss ich gucken, wie man den Controller powert über
ähm. Hat er? Ich hab jetzt geguckt, hat er jetzt fertig? Hat er jetzt ordentlich fertig geflashed? Ja. Hardware Reset, ok. So. Jetzt muss ich gucken, wie man den Controller über das Netzteil powert.
Also, machen wir wieder ab. Machen wir wieder ab. Switchen wir rüber. Auf das hier. Jetzt gucken wir, wie man den Controller über das Netzteil powert, weil bringt da nichts, wenn da ein paar USB gepowert ist.
Ich fahr übrigens gerade über mein Headset, das ist nicht gut. So. Ähm. Hol ich mal kurz das Netzteil, wenn ich wüsste, wo ich das hin hab. Hier. Jetzt gucken wir mal, wie wir das machen.
Also. Die Sache ist die. Das ist ja so ein stinknormales Netzteil hier für die Steckdose. Wie gesagt. Äh. Jetzt erkennt man es wahrscheinlich auch mit der neuen Auflösung hier.
5V, 10A. So ein ganz normales Ding. Und. Das Ding ist, oder das Problem ist. Ich muss den Kram jetzt ja irgendwie an den Controller dran kriegen.
So. Und ich hab mir mal vor einer Weile so ein paar dieser Dinger hier gekauft. Ich mach mal hier ein bisschen auf. Ah. Das ist ein bisschen flexibler ist alles.
So. Kann ich das vielleicht nämlich auch auf die Erd legen, wenn ich Glück hab? Nee, kann ich nicht. Aber ich kann es mir zumindest hier irgendwie auf den Schoß legen, dass es nicht so viel Platz braucht.
Also das da. Jetzt machen wir das da mal da drauf. So. Und da können wir jetzt ein paar Kabel dran machen. So. Und wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Moin Captain Bang. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, haben wir hier einen Pin. Einmal Ground und wir haben 5V. Kennt ihr das? 5V. Ich guck mal ob man das jetzt sieht hier.
Da. 5V. Seht ihr das? Da oben rechts. Der dritte von oben rechts. 5V. Und ich bilde mir ein. Ich hab in Erinnerung, dass man dort diesen 5V Pin als Input verwenden kann.
Da siehst du ein Icon Nano. Korrekt. Gut erkannt. Deswegen nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal zwei Kabels. Schließen das hier ans Netzteil an. Und gucken ob da der Controller startet.
Wisst ihr was ich doof finde? Dass die diese Sets von diesen Jumperkabeln nicht in einer Farbe verkaufen. Weil dann würde ich mir mal einen 50er Park Rot holen. 50er Park Schwarz und 50er Park Grün oder so. Und gut ist.
So wir nehmen mal ein Weißes. Wir nehmen mal ein Weißes. Das brauchen wir. Das ist bei den LED Strips. Ist das auch Weiß? Wo habe ich denn die LED Strips überhaupt?
Da. Das ist auch Weiß bei den LED Strips. Zumindest so ungefähr. So was ähnliches wie Weiß. Ja und komm. Wir beißen mal ins sauren Apfel und machen ein Rotes hier raus.
Gut. Ich glaube das ist jetzt nicht die feine englische Art. Wahrscheinlich weiß ich ob man das hier so nach strenger elektriker Kunst darf so was hier reinstecken. So ein Klemm Ding.
Die Matte ist bestimmt nicht ESD. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Und ich habe auch nicht mal mein ESD-Armband an. Abmahnung ist raus.
Das wird eine Steuerung für die LED Leiste hier. Und erstmal zum ausprobieren ob es überhaupt funktioniert. Ziel ist das ich das bei mir ans Bett mache. Und dann im Bewegungsfelder feststellen kann wenn ich nachts aufstehe.
Dann fade das quasi so schön ein zu so einem Gelb und wenn ich mich da wieder ins Bett reinlege dann fade das wieder aus. Soweit die Idee. Muss halt gucken wo man bleibt.
So schrauben wir das mal fest. Plus.
Ich mache mal nicht ganz so fest weil wir müssen das gleich wieder raus machen. Das ist ein Minus.
Ich mache mal nicht ganz so fest. Esquizite Idee finde ich auch. So und jetzt wenn wir Glück haben kann man es jetzt an dem 5 Volt Pin poweren.
Also sprich der hier. Guck da. Der 5 Volt Pin. Und dann einmal an Ground ran und dann hoffe das es angeht. Ansonsten Ground ist glücklicherweise auch daneben. Ich mag wie durchdacht dieses Board ist.
Mario Kart. Meinst du Karten oder Meinst du Kart. Entweder auch in den Ground oder an den Ground. Mal gucken aber es ist im Prinzip ja eh das gleiche.
So machen wir mal an und gucken ob es angeht. Schauen wir mal. Schauen wir mal hier dran. Stecker.
Wie ihr seht ist an. Ah da leucht grün. Weiß nicht ob man das sieht. Sieht man das im Stream das grün leuchtet. Also die LED vom Netzteil leucht grün.
Ich glaube da ist gerade ein Chat davor. Ich glaube direkt ein Chat davor. Ja jetzt hatten wir es gesehen. Ich habe es in der Vorschau gesehen.
Ok Leute schauen wir mal. Also hier ist die LED drauf. Wenn die blinkt dann kann man den Kram mit Strom versorgen. So wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Haha. Haha. Excellent. Sehr gut. Scheint zu funktionieren. So jetzt gucke ich mal ob der Access Point aufgeht. Chat ist was Chat ist drüber.
Ne hier ist der Chat nicht drüber. Ah da ist die LED. Chat ist nicht drüber. So ich gehe mal kurz an. Wo habe ich denn mein Handy hin?
Ich kann das Tablet verwenden aber. Ich hatte eben doch noch mein Handy in der Hand. The fuck. Na gut. Nein nicht das was filmt. Gar so hängen geblieben bin ich auch nicht.
Also ich gucke mal kurz in meine Access Points ob es da drinnen ist. Nein es ist nicht drinnen. Warum nicht?
Komisch. Hat das irgendeinen Wackelkontakt oder so vielleicht? Das war ein Wackelkontakt. Alter was ein Crap wieder. Warum hat das einen Wackelkontakt? Ich fasse es nicht.
Kacke ey. Lull. Das war ein Wackelkontakt. Ok. Dann gehen wir mal zurück auf die Webseite von denen. Weil da steht ja ein Setup Guide drauf.
Wie das funktioniert. WLED wiki. WLED wiki. So also. WLED 1234. WLED 1234. Ich zeige euch jetzt. Ich kann das euch jetzt leider nicht zeigen.
Ich kann euch das erst zeigen sobald wir in der Einrichtung sind. Weil ich will meine Access Points nicht liegen hier in der Nähe.
Guckt mal. Da sind wir. Sehr schön. Da sind wir. Welcome to WLED. Zeig China an. Da brauche ich verbündete Chat. Ich brauche mindestens 10 Abos, dass ich China anzeigen kann.
Nach 10 Abos zeige ich China an. 10x Prime reicht. Leak. Schau wieder. Schau wieder Leak. Immer Leak. Guck hier. Leak wieder. Leak. Oh nein. Da ist er. Da ist er. Habt ihr. Da ist er. Hier. Hier.
Da. Da war er. Hier ist er. Da. Jetzt kommt der. Jetzt kommt der. Navy CIS Enhanced Zoom zum tragen und dann. Da war er.
Bald gibt es Facecam Streamer. Ich sehe es schon kommen. Reflection im Tablet. So.
Ich gebe jetzt erstmal meine WIFI Settings ein. WIFI Settings. Key Pass. Ich muss mal kurz meinen Key Pass aufmachen. Und meinen WLAN Passport raussuchen.
Das weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf. LUL. Triple U. So. Also ok. Enter your WLAN Passport. Das kann ich euch jetzt leider nicht zeigen. Aber was wir machen können ist.
Ich kann euch jetzt den Exquisite ASCII Aquarium Bildschirmschoner zeigen während ich das mache.
So. Network Passport. Hoffentlich habe ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben. Ok.
Save and Connect. Ok. Mal gucken ob ich das richtig geschrieben habe. Wenn nicht muss ich nochmal neu flaschen.
Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich kann gerade nicht nachgucken. Ich suche gerade die IP von meinem Steuerungs Ding raus. Lies es. Da ist es doch. 60 128. Sehr gut.
60 128. Da sind wir Leute. Steuerung für die LEDs. Ok. Das Funst. Einzig dumme ist das Ding hatte ein bisschen Wackelkontakt. Habt ihr es gesehen?
Der Hook. 10 Monate. Dankeschön. Für den Sub. So. Guckt mal. Das hat einen Wackelkontakt. Ich weiß nicht ob ihr es eben gesehen habt. Hier. Guckt mal.
Jetzt ist aus. Und jetzt ist an. Das hat einen Wackelkontakt. Das kack Ding hier. China Crap. Naja. Was willst du machen?
So. Und jetzt können wir mal gucken ob wir die Pin Belegung umstellen können. Weil wenn wir die Pin Belegung nicht umstellen können. Ups. Ist ziemlich der Sack.
Ich glaube man kann die Pin Belegung nicht umstellen. Kann das sein? Oder seht ihr irgendwo was wo man Pin Belegung ändern kann?
Wifi Setup. Da tobsen. 2 Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub. Massive Subscriptions hier.
Ich hab keinen Bock das selbst zu kompilieren. Es wird wahrscheinlich nicht großartig schwierig sein. Aber warum kann man das wichtigste nicht im Webinterface umstellen?
Ok. Was für ein Projekt ist denn das? Ist das ein Platform IO Projekt? Ja dann ist easy. Dann klonen wir das jetzt schnell. Glaubst nicht ey. Jetzt müssen wir die Kram auch noch selbst Flashen.
Was nennt man für einen GPIO? Was nennt man? GPIO? Sucht es euch aus Chat. Nächster Sub darf sich den GPIO aussuchen. Huge Sub Incentive hier.
So. Klonen wir das mal. 69. So viel hat das Ding nicht. Hier Repos. Git clone. Ich hab keinen D2. Oder GPIO 2. Hab ich nicht. Gibt's nicht.
GPIO 2 ist intern die LED bei dem. Ja. Und das Problem ist auch noch was die sonst haben. Die haben noch ne Custom Version mit LED Pin 16.
Und Pin 16 ist auch nicht rausgeführt. Es ist Pin 18, 19, 15, 14, aber 16 nicht.
Aber vielleicht haben wir Glück und die meinen nicht GPIO 16 sondern diese interne Pin-Nummerierung 16.
Wenn die das meinen haben wir sogar halbwegs Glück. Dann können wir es nämlich nochmal mit der anderen Flashen.
D2 haben wir nicht. D2 haben wir nicht. Aber 16 haben wir. Wir haben zwar nicht GPIO 16 aber wir haben 16.
Willst du die Lampen nachbauen die du dir am Sonntag angeschaut hast? Ja. Aber jetzt erstmal ausprobieren hier mit.
Dann flashen wir den hier noch. LED Pin 16. Probieren wir es einfach mal. Ich mein probieren wir es einfach mal.
Weil guckt mal. Nein nein G2. Wir haben keinen. Wir haben keinen G2. GPIO 2 ist auf jeden Fall für die interne LED drin.
Und wir haben auch keine anderen Pins mit 2. Das gibt's nicht. Das haben wir nicht. Aber was wir haben ist Pin 16. Pin 16 haben wir das GPIO 27.
Das probieren wir mal. Weil es ist mir lieber als es selbst zu kompilieren. Ganz ehrlich.
Ach ihr seht nichts. Moment. Ja hier also. Da sieht man es ja hier. Wir haben nur. Also oben seht ihr das wir GPIO 2 ist interne an der LED.
Da können wir nichts machen. Aber wir haben einen Pin 16. Das ist hier 2. von oben links. Pin 16 aber es ist GPIO 27.
Mal gucken ob das funktioniert. Ob das mit dem Mapping hinhaut. Das kann man OTA machen. Ja. Ja ja. Hab ich schon gesehen.
Dass man das OTA machen kann.
Welches Passwort.
So. Downloads. Wo ist es?
Downloads wie LED Pin 16. Es ist Ares. Ja klar es ist richtig nice was es schon umsonst gibt.
Machen wir mal ein Update auf LED Pin 16.
LED was? Legende? Grau?
Meinst du das hier?
Oder wo?
Oder meinst du das hier?
Gucken wir mal ob das damit.
Ach hier auf der Kalle.
Was meinst du?
Meinst du das da oben?
Das bringt mir nichts. Chip Nummer. Also ein Chip Pin Nummer. Das müsste mit 16 gehen ja.
Das müsste funktionieren. Also wenn es 16 16 ist dann müsste es gehen.
So. Also hat er geflasht. Wow.
Retry.
Und KS. Was jetzt?
Hat er jetzt die WLAN Einstellung vergessen? Hat er? Muss ich jetzt nochmal WLAN Einstellungen machen oder was?
Boah. Ernsthaft?
Monarch. S.
Keine WLAN Einstellung nochmal machen.
Vielleicht muss ich doch nochmal neu flashen.
Nee der Wackelkontakt kann es nicht sein. Der blinkt ja.
Was ist denn jetzt los? Warum ist denn das jetzt weg?
Was war 128?
Ich guck mal kurz in Router ob der eine neue IP vielleicht gekriegt hat.
Nee.
Die Mac müsste gleich bleiben. Ja ich sehe euch gucke ja auch gerade im Router.
Der hat sich nicht neu gemeldet.
60 128 hatten wir. Ich starte mal neu.
Ich starte mal neu.
Man weiß ja nie.
Ja sehr gut.
Jetzt haben wir geflasht und jetzt ist er nicht mehr erreichbar.
Ist das richtig?
Ich fürchte fast wir müssen nochmal von Hand flaschen.
Dann flaschen wir nochmal von Hand.
Es kann natürlich auch sein das mit der Firmware jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Also ESP Tool, ESP Tool, Home, Max Downloads, LED und dann LED Pin 16.
Ok ich stöpsel es nochmal dran.
An USB. Flaschen wir nochmal.
Dann hoffen wir dass der sich meldet im WLAN.
Sonst funkt das nicht. Und wenn das nicht funkt nehme ich mal NodeMCU.
Habe ich keinen Bock.
Prickt. Nee so einfach. Also die Dinger prickt man wirklich ziemlich schwierig.
Das haben die auch gut gemacht. Du kannst über seriell eigentlich fast immer flaschen.
Aber wenn das nicht geht dann nehmen wir die NodeMCU und gut ist.
Die NodeMCU habe ich vorhin auch noch geflasht. Also insofern.
Da müssen wir gar nichts großartig machen. Da können wir gleich die LED Leiste anschließen.
Du du du du.
Habe ich das richtige? Vielleicht LED Pin 16.
Exzellent.
Cheater. Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal ob der sich jetzt an Route anmeldet. Ob er sich das gemerkt hat die WLAN Config.
Eigentlich nicht.
WLAN. Nein hat er sich nicht gemerkt. Aber mal gucken ob der WLAN Access Point wieder da ist.
Aber vorher muss ich euch noch was ganz wichtiges zeigen.
Ganz ganz furchtbar essentiell.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Max hat sich selbst geleakt. Immer League laufen überall.
Überall immer League.
Okay also mit dieser Firmware.
Mit der hier.
Startet er nicht. Ist ja auch geil.
Mit der Firmware geht er einfach nicht an. Ist ja toll.
Ich will mich jetzt auch nicht serial attachen weil ich nicht weiß ob der nicht vielleicht irgendwie Passwetter vom WLAN ausspuckt oder so.
Ja Leute also mit dem Controller müssen wir wahrscheinlich custom compilen und gucken ob es geht.
Das werden wir uns jetzt aber sparen und wir nehmen die NodeMCU weil mit der weiß ich dass es funktioniert.
Da habe ich vorher nämlich den Kram schon drauf geflasht aber ich wollte eigentlich nicht die NodeMCU verwenden weil der Controller hier viel kleiner ist.
Ich meine vergleiche das mal.
Das Ding versus das Ding.
Aber ich meine das Ding habe ich vorhin schon geflasht und das bootet auch mit Standardzeug.
Also insofern dann machen wir das einfach hier dran.
Dann probiere ich. Also ich werde es auf jeden Fall mit dem hier machen weil es einfach viel handlicher ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich muss ich die Firmware erstmal irgendwie ein paar Pins anpassen dass es dann bootet.
So NodeMCU das ist so das 0815 Entwickler Board was eigentlich jeder hat der mit dem ESP32 schon mal was gemacht hat.
Das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch. Du hast direkt USB auf Serial wie bei eigentlich fast allen.
Du hast massig Pins ich weiß gar nicht wie viele Pins da ist übrigens ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen schäpp.
Massig Pins hast du gar einen Knopf für Boot Reset.
Hast zwei Crown Pins sind 5 Volt Pins also der NodeMCU und die Dinger sind billig.
Also wenn ihr mal guckt was sowas kostet auf AliExpress.
Sowas kostet halt nichts.
Die kann man auch mal schrotten und das ist nicht so wild.
Mad V das hatte ich auch mit einer Steckdose.
Da musste man auch erst so eine Minitas Motorversion flashen bevor man die richtige flashen kann.
Also guckt mal der Kram ist wirklich echt billig hier.
Das ist hier so ein Board.
Warum kostet der mit fertig gelöteten Pins weniger als der mit ungelöteten Pins?
Wo ist da die Logik? Verstehe nicht.
Aber guckt mal 2 4 8 kostet der Controller also das ist eigentlich nichts.
Ok ne das kostet 3 9 8 normalerweise.
Aber wie gesagt man kann sogar bei Amazon kaufen da kostet er halt 5 Euro aber das ist halt wirklich billig der Kram.
Nein die Steckdose hat ein bisschen weniger gekostet.
So also stöpseln wir mal hier an der NodeMCU das Zeug an.
Also 5 Volt Pin ist der da.
Der da.
Crown Pin ist neben dran.
Dann schließen wir das mal an.
Gucken ob es bootet.
Sollte eigentlich ging ja eben auch noch.
Aber hoffentlich trotz Wackelkontakt.
Ups ich sehe nichts.
Hat es gebootet?
Ah jetzt.
Ok jetzt müsste eigentlich gestartet sein.
So ich ping das Ding mal und dann schauen wir.
Wenn ich die IP noch wüsste ich muss mal kurz auf meinen Router gucken.
Mein Router.
Ups.
Ne der meldet sich.
Alter.
Das Ding hat übelst einen Kack Wackelkontakt.
Das nervt mich übelst.
Was ist denn das hier?
China Kack.
Jetzt geht er auch.
Guck mal jetzt funzt er.
Jetzt blinkt er auch.
Ihr seht es nicht aber jetzt blinkt er auch.
Ihr seht es ganz leicht blinken.
Also sag mal ist das jetzt alles kaputt?
Das Ding meldet sich auch nicht im Wlan an.
Was ist denn hier gerade kaputt?
Bin ich jetzt?
Ich hab das Ding vorhin geflasht und es hat noch funktioniert?
Ist das jetzt hier alles?
Wonka Smoke?
Oder was?
Er blinkt sich?
Der Kram meldet sich nicht im Wlan?
Ne an ist er.
An ist er.
Der blinkt ja.
Ich mach mal kurz hier das Netzteil aus.
Wo geht überhaupt das?
Also wir machen das Netzteil einfach.
Wir machen das Netzteil einfach hier aus.
Aber ich will den Wackelkontakt nicht anfassen.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich das vorher genauso...
Nee ich hatte das vorher nicht so angeschlossen.
Ich bin ja doof.
Ich weiß ich hab's verkehrt rum angeschlossen.
Ich muss den...
Ne ne ne das ist richtig wie ich's gemacht hab.
Der einzige Unterschied ist...
Ich darf glaube ich...
Ja geh mal aus.
Ich muss den Crown hier unten nehmen.
Den da.
Den hier.
Dann geht's.
Das hatte ich vorhin schon mal.
Da bin ich auch nicht drauf gekommen.
Da ist er.
60 130.
Ja.
Keine Ahnung was das für ein Crap ist.
Aber jetzt geht's.
Da sind wir.
Gut.
Also.
Jetzt können wir die LED-Leiste konfigurieren.
Wir schließen da dran eine LED-Leiste an.
Mit.
Äh.
LED-Preferences.
Wir schließen da eine LED-Leiste an.
Mit.
Nur RGB?
Ob das GRB, RGB, BR, GR, BG, BGR oder B...
GBR ist hab ich keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich GRB.
So.
Das lassen wir einfach so.
Ach so ist das.
Aha.
Wunder...
Ich hab mich schon gewundert.
Warum das an dem Pin nicht geht.
So.
Äh.
Back.
Ja dann schauen wir mal.
Dann schließen wir jetzt mal den LED-Strip an.
Äh.
Dazu muss ich nur mal irgendwie das komische Netzteil hier vom Tisch woanders hin befördern.
In der Hoffnung ich löse keinen Wackelkontakt aus.
Das ist ja bei dem Teil, ne.
Man weiß ja nie.
Äh.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Ich schalte euch erstmal wieder auf die Kamera.
Jetzt überlegen wir uns mal wie wir das Ganze machen.
Hast du eine Werkzeugempfehlung?
Ja.
Wenn du dir nur eine Sache kaufen kannst, dann hol dir das hier.
Das da.
Ich bin nicht gesponsert von Vera, aber das ist eines der besten Sachen die man sich so
für den Haushalt, für den Haushalt holen kann.
Das hat.
Ich mache mal kurz ab.
Ich kann es mal kurz zeigen.
Äh.
Warum machen wir das jetzt am besten hin mit dem Netzteil hier neben hin?
Ja.
Also du hast einmal.
Griff.
Du hast einen Bithalter.
Einen ziemlich praktischen Bithalter.
Du hast ähm.
So eine Mini-Ratsche.
Ja.
Ratsche, Ratsche, Ratsche.
Ähm.
Und du hast so die üblichen Nüsse, die man ab und zu mal vielleicht braucht.
Und alle möglichen Bits, die man so mal gebrauchen kann.
Also das Tool-Check-Plus ist, wenn man sich sonst nichts kauft.
Wenn man es einzig ist, was man sich kauft, dann das.
Ich schrei.
Genau.
Ich sag Werra.
Easy.
Sponsor.
Sponsort mich.
Ganz ehrlich.
Wenn ich mich dazu aufraffen könnte, die Chancen stehen wahrscheinlich ganz schlecht.
Ich meine.
Ich habe immer einen YouTube-Channel mit 250.000, 270.000 Abos.
Und mache hier Technik-Grams im Stream.
Und da gucken jetzt so wenige Leute.
Ich meine für Technik-Stream gucken hier wirklich relativ viele immer zu.
Das sind ja eigentlich immer 100 plus.
Oder eigentlich eher 150 plus immer.
Also da kannst du wirklich nichts sagen.
So.
Wie kriegen wir das jetzt am besten angeschlossen?
Also zeige ich mal her.
Wir müssen jetzt bei dem Strip hier.
Bei dem Strip.
Ich brauche ein bisschen Platz.
So also.
Bei dem Strip.
Wir müssen.
Also der hat.
Zeig mal her.
Wo ist denn hier vorne da.
Der hat hier verschiedene Anschlüsse.
Das hier dürfte plus und minus für den Strom sein.
Wenn man es direkt ans Netzteil anschließt.
Aber letztendlich können wir plus und minus auch den da oder den da nehmen.
Das macht im Prinzip gar nichts aus.
Weil unter der Haube kommen die zwei Kabel eher auf den gleichen Pins hier raus.
Also ihr seht.
Man kann den LED Strip auch hier durchschneiden.
Und hier wieder neu anlöten.
Also das ist kein Problem.
Man kann dementsprechend auch.
Wenn es zu dunkel.
Wir zwischendrin Strom rein machen und sowas.
Und ups.
Ich hänge mit dem Headset fest.
So und das grüne.
Das ist der Daten PIN.
Soweit habe ich mir das vorher mal in so einem Diagram angeguckt.
Ich habe nicht wahnsinnig Plan.
Aber ich habe letztes Jahr zu Weihnachten schon mal so ein Ding angeschlossen.
So ein ähnliches.
Für Weihnachtsbaum.
Und ich glaube ich kann mich auch so halbwegs dran erinnern.
So.
Also hier haben wir unsere Controller dran.
Plus minus.
Was man was man machen kann.
Was ich aber nicht empfehlen würde ist.
Man kann den hier powern über den PIN auf dem NodeMCU.
Würde ich aber nicht machen.
Ich würde es immer ans Netzteil anschließen.
Weil die PINs vom NodeMCU machen glaube ich maximal.
1500mAh oder sogar nur 1800mAh.
Das reicht da nicht sonderlich viel.
Das reicht für ein paar Pixel.
Und dann ist gut.
Würde ich nicht machen.
Schließ lieber direkt ans Netzteil an.
Genau suchen wir uns mal ein grünes Kabel für ein Daten PIN raus.
Ah grünes Kabel.
Exzellent.
So.
Und in Ermangelung.
Irgendwelches anderen Werkzeuges oder sonst wie.
Werden wir das jetzt mal so machen.
Wie es wahrscheinlich dem Elektriker gleich die Haare zu Berge stehen lässt.
Ähm.
Nämlich.
Wir nehmen einfach.
Hier ein Kabel.
Ein rotes Kabel und ein schwarzes Kabel.
Und machen das.
Klemmen das noch dabei rein.
Also ein rotes Kabel.
Und haben wir noch ein schwarzes hier.
Da haben wir noch ein schwarzes Kabel.
Die sind aber nicht gleich lang.
Haben wir noch ein paar gleich lange.
Hoffe ich mal.
Exzellent.
Hallo.
Geh mal zusammen.
Inwiefern modifizierst du die Leiste jetzt.
Mit der Leiste selbst mache ich dann nicht großartig.
Die Leiste bleibt erstmal Leiste.
Ich meine die bleibt nicht so wie sie ist.
Vielleicht müssen wir noch ein paar Zutinger wenn es zu dunkel wird anlöten.
Das was wir heute gelötet haben waren die Pins vom Controller.
Von einem anderen Controller und ein bisschen Zeug.
Aber die Leiste an sich die bleibt.
Die bleibt eigentlich so wie sie ist.
Muss übrigens mal wieder meine Vorschau auf dem Tablet anmachen.
Ausgegangen ist.
Live.
Wo ist da wo bloß.
Sonst übersehe ich die ganzen Sachen die im Chat kommen.
Welche Stromaufnahme hat der ganze Ding.
Ja also laut dem Datendings vom Hersteller maximal 90 Watt.
Allerdings.
Ich habe nur einen.
Ich habe nur einen 5 Watt 10 Ampere Netzteil.
Also maximal 50 Watt.
Ich denke ja das reicht.
Hallo wie geht es.
Jetzt geht es gut weil jetzt funktioniert es hoffentlich.
So also das ist unsere Datenleitung.
Dann stecken wir mal kurz hier den Kram in.
Plus.
Und den stecken wir in Minus.
Ich habe übrigens das falsche Kabel genommen.
Das macht man normalerweise im Stecker der besser passt.
Aber ich habe keinen Stecker der besser passt.
Mit W LED ins Smart Home.
Ja das ist 5 Volt genau.
Allerdings wie gesagt ich schließe die nicht an Controller an.
Sondern die kommen ans Netzteil dran.
So und jetzt jetzt machen wir mal eine Sache.
Nachdem ich nichts habe hier anderes wie man das machen kann.
Also ich habe hier keine Dinge die man drüber machen kann.
Ich habe auch keine Klemmen gerade da.
Ich könnte ein paar Klemmen holen.
Aber wisst ihr was wir stecken das jetzt einfach damit rein.
Ich meine so zum Testen geht das ja.
Der Elektriker sagt jetzt wahrscheinlich MonkaS.
Aber ja.
Da muss er mit leben.
Guck mal wie schön es hier rausguckt neben.
Hast du eine Katze ja.
Deswegen sind meine Hände so verkratzt.
So.
Zack.
Und voll gucken dass nichts aneinander kommt.
Ja gut.
Man darf von abgesehen passieren tut einem da nichts.
Also um mich um mich oder um die Katze mache ich mir da keine Gedanken.
Wo ich mache jetzt auch mal richtig fest.
Wo ich mir da Gedanken mache ist wenn ich hier nicht aufpasse.
Ich den Controller vielleicht grille.
Aber ansonsten.
So also wir haben alles angeschlossen.
Datenleitung muss GPIO 2 da G2.
Nimm 2.
Und wenn wir jetzt alles richtig gemacht haben.
Geht die Leiste oder geht der Strip an.
Den wir nicht Strip nennen dürfen weil Twitch sagt Strip ist MonkaS.
Dann schauen wir mal ich lege das jetzt so prestigeträchtig hier mal hin.
In der Hoffnung man sieht gleich dass es angeht.
Wahrscheinlich geht es nicht an.
Pause Champ Pause Champ.
Und jetzt hoffe ich ich erwische nicht gleich wieder den Wackelkontakt.
Oh ho ho Poggers seht ihr das.
Easy Easy.
Funktioniert.
So wir müssen den jetzt einmal mal ausrollen.
Das wird schwierig.
Wo wo wo.
Ok Moment.
Wie rolle ich denn den hier jetzt am besten aus.
Wie roll ich denn den hier jetzt am besten aus.
Also ich muss ich muss.
Oh hier hier Spiegel Champ wieder.
Ist das Spiegel aus.
Erstmal das Netzteil hier irgendwo hinlegen wo nicht so viel im Weg liegt.
Das kommt da hin.
Gut.
Das Tablet brauchen wir noch dass ich was sehe das kommt da hin.
Der ganze andere Krempel den schmeiß ich da hin und mal in die Eck.
Den brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
So der Controller der bleibt halt hier liegen weil was sollst du sonst machen.
Und jetzt rollen wir mal aus.
Jetzt rollen wir mal aus.
Roll Champ machen wir jetzt.
Richtiger richtiger Roll Champ.
Die Musik passt da richtig gut zum Roll Champ.
Zum Koggers Moment ich brauche das passende E-Mode.
Sekunde ich brauche ich brauche ich brauche das passende E-Mode dafür.
So.
Fünf Meter sind halt schon ein ganz schön Stück.
Fünf Meter sind fünf Meter.
Das ist schon ein bisschen was.
Roll Champ Koggers oder Koggers in den Chat.
Fünf Meter sind schon ein Stück.
Alter haben wir es bald immer.
Bäm.
So.
Ups bin ich voll im Knie dagegen gerannt.
Viel zu hell Dark Mode.
Ja wir machen jetzt das Licht aus.
Wir machen jetzt das Licht aus.
So habe ich den Schalter fürs Licht.
Und ich mache mal kurz das Licht allgemein aus.
Oh.
Exzellent.
Eine exzellent weihnachtliche Beleuchtung haben wir hier jetzt am Start.
Kannst du WLAN Verstärker empfehlen?
Repeater ist nicht so das beste.
Also nur wenn man es wirklich unbedingt braucht.
Hast du schon mal erlebt ein Ambilight selbst zu basteln?
Nein.
Ich habe ein Ambilight.
Aber kein Ambilight am Fernsehen eingebaut.
Sondern so ein Dreamscreen hatte ich mir damals gekauft.
Also ich würde Unify Access Points empfehlen, wenn es was Gescheites sein darf.
Oder was auch ganz praktisch ist, wenn du einen Rechner anschließen willst.
Nimm den Access Point und stell den in den Klein Modus.
Und schließ das dann per Kabel an den Access Point an.
Besser als ein Repeater auf jeden Fall.
So, also.
Dann stellen wir jetzt mal hier unseren WLED Champ ein.
Wir machen das mal so, dass man hier ein bisschen was sieht.
Ja, so ist es glaube ich nicht so.
Ok, also was kann man hier einstellen?
Weiß.
By the way.
Das sieht blau wegen der Unterlage aus, aber es ist weiß.
Allerdings, und da bin ich auch mal gespannt.
Ich würde eigentlich damit rechnen, dass zumindest manche Effekte nicht durchgängig funktionieren.
Wir machen mal blau und gucken, ob alle blau werden.
Bis jetzt werden alle blau.
So, wir inspizieren mal kurz die LEDs.
Ob das, weil ich hätte auch, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das wirklich über die komplette.
Ah, wisst ihr was?
Mal gucken, vielleicht müssen wir die Helligkeit noch hochstellen hier.
Was passiert bei schwarzen?
Das geht aus.
Schwarzes Licht gibt es ja irgendwie nicht.
Ah, seht ihr, jetzt kommt der volle Helligkeit klappt nicht mehr.
Seht ihr das?
Hier, am Ende sind die Dinger gelb anstatt weiß.
Das probieren wir jetzt noch mal zu fixen.
Ich glaube, man erkennt es, oder?
Hier, guck mal, die sind gelb, obwohl sie eigentlich weiß sein sollten.
Das liegt daran, weil das ist nur, das sind 5 Volt-LEDs.
Und der Widerstand durch das Kabel ist so lang, ist so groß, auch wenn es nicht viel ist,
aber es sind halt nur 5 Volt, dass am Ende vielleicht noch, und man sieht es auch, es wird immer weniger.
Hier fangen sie an gelb zu werden und dann werden sie immer oranger auf dem Weg zum Ende.
Da sind am Ende vielleicht dann noch 4 Volt übrig oder so.
So, deswegen sind die Farben anders.
Das versuchen wir jetzt mal schnell zu fixen, indem ich hier hinten auch noch mal Strom anschließe.
Was heißt, ich muss noch ein drittes Kabel in den Anschluss reinfuddeln?
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass mein Netzteil zu schwach ist.
Ich muss noch ein drittes Kabel in den Anschluss reinfuddeln.
So, ich mache mal kurz Licht an, dass ich wieder was sehe hier.
Also mal kurz hier den da zumindest.
Den da.
Mal kurz raus, zack.
Es ist jetzt hier relativ dunkel, ich weiß, aber ich habe halt Licht aus.
Wenn nicht die Ampere weniger statt Widerstand wird, die Volt weniger, die Spannung weniger.
Deswegen hast du auch ein Problem, wenn du 5 Volt-Netzteile in den Keller anschließt und willst das irgendwo quer durchs Haus legen und dann was anstöpseln.
So, also jetzt probieren wir das mal.
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen eklig und zwar, wir haben ja hier schon...
Die Kabel werden recht warm.
Vielleicht sollte ich da ein bisschen was dickeres verwenden.
Fragezeichen-Chamber, mal gucken.
Also, das heißt wir müssen da jeweils noch ein Kabel reinmachen.
Okay, dann machen wir das mal.
Mal gucken, ob ich das da noch reinkriege überhaupt.
So, reinstecke.
Irgendwie, zack, bam, passt.
Excellent. Seht ihr überhaupt was? Ja.
Und jetzt einfach ordentlich Schmugges zumachen.
Was vom Netzteil?
Was habe ich übersehen im Chat?
Auf dem Tablet-Chat-Verfolgen ist ein bisschen doof.
Übrigens, ich habe das falsche Kabel reingemacht. Ich brauche hier ein anderes Kabel.
Okay, Paint-Chamber, noch mal raus.
Die Drähte haben 0,25 mm. Ja, das ist ja...
Ja, und? Ja, und?
Das lasse ich mir ja auch nicht so.
Komm, wir nehmen jetzt hier mal das orange Kabel.
Anders da rein.
Fachmännisch korrekt, wie man das hier so macht.
Fest das Ganze.
Schützt, passt, wackelt, nicht, hat auch keine Luft.
So, hier dran.
Passt das nicht?
Doch, excellent.
So, und dann hier brauchen wir noch eins.
Nehmen wir das gelbe, ist eigentlich wurscht.
Machen das auf der anderen Seite rein.
Wie gesagt, how-to nicht anschließen, by the way.
Also, wahrscheinlich, also wenn ich das jetzt ordentlich mache, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich Folgendes machen.
Ich nehme erstmal ein bisschen dickere Kabel.
Dann nehme ich mir eine Klemme und mache, ähm, irgendwie so eine Vago-Klemme oder sowas.
Und mache davor nochmal drei Stück und stöpsel das dann an.
Wie lange ist das schon? Fünf Meter.
Zwieg doch bei den Pins vom Draht ab.
Also, da müsste ich hier was dazwischen machen.
Also, ich will jetzt nicht hier an die Pins das betreiben, den LED-Strip.
Da brennt mir nochmal ein Raspberry durch.
Auf, geh rein, Alter.
Ah, perfekt. So macht man es.
Nicht.
Zack, zack.
Oh.
Es ist nicht fest, Leute.
Es ist überhaupt nicht fest.
Oh, die Musik ist aus. Ich brauche Kirby-Musik oder irgendwas.
Das ist nicht, äh, beruhigt mich sonst nicht.
Jawoll. Alter, Tastatur, please.
Zack.
Meinst du?
Meinst du mit wie? Na ja.
Mal kurz gucken, wie ich das jetzt dran bekomme.
Excellent.
So, jetzt ist das, jetzt ist das alles schön fest. Sieht zwar exquisite toll, gut gemacht aus, ja.
Nee, nee, ich glaube, ich nehme ein bisschen dickere Kabels.
Weil das ist schon, das wird schon ganz schön, das wird schon ganz schön warm hier oben dann.
Okay, jetzt schließen wir es mal an und jetzt gucken wir, ob das dann mit den LEDs besser funktioniert.
So, also ich muss noch kurz gucken. Hier ist Crown, da ist Plus, zack.
Gut, Daten PIN müssen wir nicht anschließen.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das mit den Strips besser funktioniert.
Hoffentlich habe ich nicht den Wackelkontakt getroffen. Vom, vom Stegge.
Sehen wir, sehen wir jetzt gleich, wenn nämlich das hier funktioniert.
Ah, easy Wackelkontakt, beste. Ah.
Da sind wir. So, mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Volle Pulle auf Orange geht und auf Weiß. Volle Pulle Weiß.
Yo, das sieht gut aus. Alle LEDs Weiß, auch am Ende.
Guckt, jetzt sind sie auch am Ende Weiß. Wahnsinn, vorher noch nicht.
So ist das nice.
Hast du schon mal mit Raspberry oder Fosk gearbeitet?
Nee, das Problem, also Raspberry oder wie das man das ausspricht,
wollte ich schon mal ausprobieren, aber dass man das nicht über die App verwenden kann, fand ich doof.
Ich will mir ja keine Raspberry Pi im Haus verteilen.
Ja, das liegt an der Katze, dass die Hände so verkratzt sind.
Korrekt. Also ein bisschen dickere Kabel wären glaube ich echt nicht verkehrt.
Was macht man mit den separaten Treten?
Nix, die kommen auf den gleichen Pins raus, also die hier meinst du, ne?
Wow, wenn die Kabel heiß, Alter.
Okay Leute, da müssen dickere Kabel dran. Alter.
Anzeige ist raus.
Also die zusätzlichen Sachen hier, die gehen an die gleichen Pins wie die hier.
Das ist, wenn man die direkt von irgendeinem Netzteil speisen will und nicht da drüber.
Alter Falder.
Ja gut, die hier an ESP gehen aber.
Gleich kommt, gleich brennt es, Alter.
Mock as Mock.
Ich mach mal aus. Ich mach mal aus.
Das wird ein bisschen warm.
Ich mach mal Licht an, ich geh mal kurz Licht an.
Ich lass mal aus, das ist ein bisschen viel für die kleinen Kackträne.
Ja, ich hab das gesehen.
Was soll ich denn jetzt machen?
Müß ich erst mal Kabel suchen.
Sehr gut, ähm, tja.
Also was lernen wir da draus?
Ordentliche Kabel verwenden, die nicht so futzdünn kleine Kackkabel sind wie die.
Ich guck mal, ich guck mal kurz, ich glaub ich hab hier noch was Besseres.
Ich geh mal kurz um die Ecken schauen.
Ja.
Ha, Chet, was war denn mit denen hier?
Ich glaub die sind besser, oder?
So welche hier.
Die sind schon ein bisschen dicker.
Die müssten glaub ich besser funktionieren.
Das ist Klingeldraht, ja.
Die sind doppelt oder dreimal so dick wie meine Jumperwire.
Ich hab auch noch richtig dicke, aber die brauchen wir dafür wahrscheinlich nicht, ja.
Gibt es keine direkten LEDs, doch, doch, doch.
Mindestens 0,75.
Was ist denn, was ist denn, was sind denn das, was sind denn das für Dinger hier?
Oh Mist, da ist jetzt ein LED-Kabel runter gefallen.
Sind das für Dinger 0,2?
Wie ist denn das?
Die müssten doch ausreichen.
Das sind, äh, ich zeige euch mal was das für Kabel sind.
Also, mal festhalten, nicht nachmachen, ja.
Also, wo habe ich die Dinger denn hier?
Hm.
Ja, wenn ich die finden würde.
Ich habe leider keinen Amazon-Zugriff auf meinem zweiten Rechner.
Könnte ich da besser suchen.
Das sind so, das sind so normale Dinger, die man, die man auch zur, äh, zur Verkabelung von irgendwie Tür-Gegensprecher-Anlage oder sowas verwendet.
Hm, ich finde es jetzt auf Amazon halt.
Ja, mit denen können wir das mal ausprobieren.
Also, ich habe auch noch dickere.
Also, ich habe, ich habe so welche, die man, pass mal auf.
Ich guck mal, wo habe ich denn die Rolle?
Moment, wo habe ich denn die Rolle?
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
Tschüss mal kurz, guck mal, wo ist die Rolle mit den Kabel?
Oh, die habe ich sogar hier.
Die habe ich sogar hier.
Hast du kein defektes PC-Netzteil?
Doch, aber warum? Wozu?
Gucken die, glaube ich, habe ich sogar hier.
Hier sind sie nicht, sind sie hier.
So, die reichen, oder?
Ich hätte auch noch, ich hätte auch noch sowas hier zu bieten.
Ich hätte auch noch sowas hier zu bieten.
Es geht das auch. 0,8.
Die sind, glaube ich, ein bisschen handlicher.
Also, Chad, welche nehme ich? Die reichen, oder? Die anderen sind ein bisschen zu fett.
Fuck, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, wo ich meine abisolierte Zange habe.
Nein, ohne abisolierte Zange krebs ich mir da doch ein mega ab jetzt.
Zeig noch mal hier.
Oder ich hätte noch die fetten, Alter.
Nimm lieber Glasfaser.
Also, die hier, die kriege ich da überhaupt nicht richtig rein, oder?
Scheiß drauf. Komm, wir nehmen jetzt die fetten, Alter.
Wir nehmen jetzt die richtig fetten Kabel.
Easy.
Also, ich habe, ich habe, für die fetten habe ich gar keine abisolierte Zange da.
Da habe ich nur so ein, da habe ich nur so ein Ding, so ein billiges Teil.
Das müsste da aber reichen.
Geht das damit überhaupt?
Du kannst die 10 nehmen. Exquisite Idee.
Das passt hier überhaupt nicht rein, Alter. Guck dir mal.
Das ist, ich habe mit so fetten Kabel mache ich eigentlich so gut wie nie was. Guck mal.
Normalerweise macht man das hier vorne rein, oder kann man das abisolieren?
Das passt nicht da rein.
Man kann das ja hochdrehen hier. Man kann das ja hochdrehen.
Kann das ja hochdrehen. Vielleicht passt das jetzt rein.
Excellent. Ah, easy, easy. Gleich habe ich es.
Haha.
Aber jetzt kann man es nicht mehr drehen, oder?
Oh, oh, oh, oh. Pause-Camp, Pause-Camp.
Pause-Camp, Pause-Camp.
Pause, Pause-Camp.
Bam.
Das war zwar mehr schlecht als recht, aber, aber Kabel-Camp.
So, ich brauche mal eben eine Zange.
Nur eine kurze Zange holen, Alter.
Muss abzumachen.
Jetzt haben wir ordentliche Kabel.
Ups.
So.
Kennst du noch andere Streamer, die so einen Content wie ich machen?
Nee. Ich glaube, das gibt es auf Twitch nicht so viel.
So, guck mal, ich habe noch so eine, für ein bisschen dickere Kabel,
Abisoliert-Zange gefunden.
Ich habe eigentlich so eine automatische, wo man so Klick-Klick macht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das geht für die dicken Kabel.
Ah.
Achtung, Schnipp-Schnap-Camp.
Schneide-Camp.
Alter.
So.
Pop-Los ist einzigartig, ja.
Gut.
Dann gucken wir mal, ne?
Also, da.
Ich mache sowas normalerweise nicht.
Chat-Bus-Big-Brain zur Seite stehen.
Also, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Ich habe hier noch irgendwo ein paar Klemmen.
Ich habe hier noch so ein paar Dinge.
Die passen hier eigentlich ganz gut dafür, denke ich.
Dann machen wir das jetzt mal ordentlich.
Dann machen wir das jetzt mal ordentlich, also.
Mr.Klemsor.
Kann man Kabel an Kabel löten?
Kann man machen, ja.
Aber mit so einer Klemme finde ich es irgendwie schicker.
So.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Ich meine, hier.
Hier kriege ich ja maximal ein Kabel von den Fetten rein.
Ich meine, mehr passt hier im Leben nicht rein.
Ich kriege das gar nicht mehr auf.
Ganz ein Schmodder mal raus, ja.
So.
Wie macht man das jetzt am besten?
Weil, weil.
Die Sache ist ja die.
Ich muss den Kram irgendwie hier dran bekommen.
Und ich habe da nicht die passenden Stecker für.
Wie kriege ich das da?
Nein.
Weil die Fetten Kabel kriege ich da ja nicht im Leben rein.
Vielleicht ist doch besser.
Vielleicht doch besser.
Ich nehme die.
Weil die passen.
Abschneiden und Klemme.
Will ich das nicht abschneiden?
Was man nicht alles macht.
Okay.
Also, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Wo ist denn der?
Da.
Also, ich meine, hier kann ich doch schon mal.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt den Grauen hin?
Chat, wo habe ich das graue Kabel hingelegt?
Wo ist es?
Grauer Kabelchamp?
Da.
Hier ist es.
Ich glaube, die ist ein bisschen zu eng eingestellt.
Wie kriegt man diesen Kack überhaupt auf, Alter?
Ah, so, exellent.
So, und nun?
Und nun stecken wir das da rein, oder wie?
Oh, das ist natürlich schon mal ganz anderes Ding, was da jetzt im Kabel drin steckt.
Das ist mal ein ordentliches Kabel.
Was hat er nicht?
So, das ist schon mal ordentlich hier.
Also, da geht nichts raus, Alter.
Was mir eher Gedanken macht, ist, wie kriege ich das hier dran?
Ich meine, okay, die hier sind ja kein Problem.
Der brauche ich nicht.
Aber, ähm, ich meine, ich kann ja die hier nehmen.
Ich kann ja die hier nehmen, da muss ich das Ding halt abmachen.
Ich kann ja die Kabel nehmen.
Ich mache einfach das hier ab und klemme die und klemme die fest.
Boah, das müsste doch funktionieren.
Es müsste doch klappen.
Also, ich mache die hier mal ab.
Ich glaube, ich habe die ein bisschen eng eingestellt.
Ja, passt.
Hier, so.
Gehen die Dinger überhaupt mit diesen Klemmen hier?
Ich habe die noch nie verwendet.
Ich habe diese Sorten Klemmen noch nie verwendet.
Ich habe noch ein paar andere.
Ich habe noch so die oldschool Dinger.
Ich habe noch so die oldschool, ich habe noch die Dinger.
Klemmchamp habe ich noch.
Klemmchamp.
Kann ich denn, kann ich denn das da auch da rein machen?
Die mit dem Hebel.
Da habe ich aber ein Kabel zu wenig.
Ein Kabel zu wenig.
Die sind perfekt, okay.
Ich habe dann aber ein Kabel zu wenig, weil ich brauche ein Kabel da.
Ein Kabel in den ESP und ein Kabel in die LED-Leiste und noch eins.
Kann ich nicht in einen Beides rein klemmen?
Nee, nee, das glaube ich keine gute Idee, oder?
By the way, warum haben die Dinger hier so ein Loch?
Zwei dünne Kabel geht, aber ich habe nur ein dünnes Kabel.
Also ich habe nur, ich brauche nur für das dünn, für das andere brauche ich dick.
Nein, ich kann doch einfach zwei Klemmen aneinander machen, oder?
Im Zweifelsfall mache ich aber zwei Klemmen aneinander.
So, also, also.
Das heißt, ich klemme erstmal den da rein, ne?
Die Dinger, da habe ich, die Taktik habe ich nicht so genau verstanden.
Die macht man auf, schiebt es dann wie weit rein?
Also ich meine, und dann muss man halt übelst, dann macht es klick und die Dinger sind fest.
Okay, also.
Das heißt, wir machen jetzt erstmal den da rein.
Da muss ich nichts machen, ne?
Die kann man einfach so da reinstecken, wie sie sind.
So.
Bis zum Anschlag, exzellent.
Alter, so.
Okay, das ist, das ist ordentlich fest.
Da gibt es nichts zu meckern.
Da gibt es wirklich nichts zu meckern.
So.
Kann man da, mal blöde Frage.
Kann man da die da rein machen?
Die Jumperkabel?
Weil ich meine, für den ESP, der braucht ja nichts im Endeffekt.
Der wird ja auch nicht warm.
Kann man da, kann man da sowas hier reinklemmen, so?
Okay, so.
Also, lass, lass mal überlegen.
Das haben wir da drin.
Dann brauchen wir da jetzt.
Ich weiß, was ich mache.
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab die Big Brain Idee.
Ich klemme, ich klemme das da noch dabei.
Geht doch bestimmt, oder?
Kann man das da noch dabei klemme?
Okay, also.
Dann machen wir jetzt das nächste noch da rein, dass es passt.
Nämlich die Seite.
Die andere Seite, die machen wir noch rein.
Ups.
Und KS.
So.
Oh fuck.
Hab ich von dem Kabel was mit?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Fuck, ich glaube, ich hab vom Kabel was mit abgerissen.
Alter, dieses Kackding, wo hab ich meine richtig gute,
wo hab ich meine ordentliche Abisolierzange, Alter?
Mit dem Kackding kannst du nichts mehr anfangen.
Etwas länger abisolieren.
Warte mal, wo hab ich die Zange, ey?
Hab ich die hier drin?
Das Ding ist übelst das Sack, was ich da hab.
Na, egal.
Okay, müssen wir ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein.
Also schneiden wir noch mal ab.
Schneiden wir noch mal ab.
Ja, schnapp, schnapp.
Ein bisschen länger, also so.
Mist, jetzt zu.
Aha.
Aha, exellent.
Das sind aber ganz schön dünne Kabels auch an sich, ne?
Gut, also machen wir den hier auf.
Oder wir machen beide mal auf.
Zack und zack.
Dann machen wir das da rein.
Bis zum Anschlag.
Bam.
Gut, hängt.
Dann machen wir den hier noch dran.
Der ist ein bisschen kurz, oder?
Reicht das oder muss ich den länger abisolieren?
Reicht, oder?
Sagt mal, Chat, reicht das oder muss ich noch ein bisschen mehr?
Es reicht.
Oh, das ist bombenfest, Alter.
Bombenfest, ey.
Exquisite.
So ist das gut.
So, nächste Klemme.
An der Seite, an der Seite.
Aha, das ist ein bisschen kurz, da muss ich noch ein Stückchen machen.
So, das ist gut.
Klemmsor.
Mister Klemmsor.
Die Klemmen, die sind echt nice, ne?
Da gibt's nix, also die sind wirklich Poggers.
Ups.
Aha.
Ja.
War nix.
So, das hält.
Das ist fest.
So, jetzt nehmen wir den hier, irgendwas.
Den da.
Und machen da noch so einen fetten rein.
Und machen den dann hier dran.
So, und jetzt ist nur die Frage, wie schließe ich meinen ESP an?
Kann ich meinen ESP da noch mit rein klemmen?
Irgendwie so?
Man macht ja eigentlich keinen Unterschied, ob das jetzt da drin klemmt oder da oben drin
klemmt.
Ich mach da halt auch gleich noch.
So, perfekt.
So, hier die da, zack.
Bombenfest, alter.
Gut, hier noch, nein.
Ah, guck mal, es guckt raus, das ist nett schön, ne?
Machen wir noch ein Stückchen ab.
Oh, jetzt fliegt hier irgendwo der Kabel rum.
What the f...
So, jetzt ist nur die Frage, wie kriege ich da meinen ESP dran?
Vertausche Plus und Minus nicht.
Ich würde sagen, ist alles gut, hier die zwei roten sind an Plus und hier die grauen
und weißen, die sind dann an Minus, also, ich würd sagen, das passt.
So, jetzt stopfen wir da den ESP noch dabei, ich hoffe, dass das ist okay, weil ich hab
keinen Platz mehr sonst.
Ups, nee, das ist nur zum Ausprobieren und ehrlich gesagt, ich war eigentlich schon zufrieden
mit vorher, aber nachdem ich das noch nie gemacht hab mit den fetten Dingern, mir gedacht,
probieren wir das jetzt noch mal aus.
Kannst den ESP an den schwarzen drei Pol stecken.
Stimmt, big brain, Alter, chat, poggers, das müsste gehen, das müsste gehen.
Gut, dann schließen, machen wir das mal an.
Umgebungsbeleuchtung reduzieren, die hatten wir ja vorhin schon.
Okay, jetzt ist fest, jetzt ist sowas von fester, also sprich, ich kann jetzt wirklich,
das müsste echt funktionieren, das müsste gehen, ich kann den hier, ich kann meinen
G einfach da dran machen, oder, theoretisch müsste es gehen, Datapin, jetzt halt ein bisschen
eng hier, Mann, wir machen jetzt keinen doofen Witz.
Okay, gut, so jetzt, jetzt bin ich ja mal höchst gespannt, ob das klappt, jetzt hoffen
wir, dass wir es nicht erwischen mit Wackelkontakt von Stecker, so ich hoffe, ich hab nichts
vertauscht, bam, und da wird auch nichts mehr warm jetzt, exquisite, Moment, ich mach Licht
aus, mach das mal kurz über den Home Assistant aus, dafür hab ich ihn ja, ah yes, so ist
was, gut, was ein Akt, was ein Akt, so Kabel, alles schön kühl, jetzt, die Kabel hier auch,
die sind dick genug, und die, oh, Wackel, ein nicer Wackelkontakt, ey, alter, der China-Stecker,
er macht mich fertig, ich will, ich will den Kram hier eigentlich aus dem Bild, so, sehr
gut, sehr gut, sehr gut, exzellent, exzellent, so, ja, Chat, schön, dass ihr hier mitgeholfen
habt, und zwar wirklich ernsthaft, auch der, ich hab vergessen, der Setke, irgendein Setke
war im Chat, der hat sinnvolle Sachen gesagt, ich muss ja sagen, mein Chat ist eh der beste,
was das angeht, da kommen sinnvolle Sachen bei rum, ok, volle Brightness, bam, in your
face, zack, und alles ist weiß, alles ist weiß, so, das ist jetzt voller, volle Pulle
Verbrauch, ne, nö, wisst ihr was, da wird nix warm, da wird nix warm, alles gut, alles
gut, zeig mal die Effekte, genau, die Effekte gucken wir uns jetzt an, da muss ich das aber
noch ein bisschen verteilen für die Effekte, ne, guck ich mir gleich, Chat, ich geh eh
gleich noch mal den Chat durch, ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen Platz machen, oh Gott,
China Crap, die LEDs sind einzeln ansteuerbar, ja, ey, das China Zeug, ich krieg Anfälle,
setge, richtig setge ist das China Zeug, ich hab Urlaub bis Ende des Jahres, jupp, das
sind WS, China, Alter, das sind, genau, das sind WS2812B, genau, so siehts aus, so, ich
versuch das mal ein bisschen besser zu verteilen jetzt, die LEDs werden auch ganz gut warm,
Kabel selbst werden absolut nicht warm, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, also, du merkst ganz
ein bisschen, dass die warm werden, aber die werden nicht heiß, oder so, bei Zweifelverkommnung
dickere Kabels ranlöten, Alter, please, China, China, werden
dicke Kabel nicht einfach nur noch heißer, weiß ich, also die gehen gerade, ey, das Ding
ist übelst kacke, diese, dieser Sucker Verbindung, äh, übrigens, der Stecker wird auch relativ
warm hier, weiß nicht, ob der dafür so, so gut, so gut gemacht ist, ja, vielleicht soll
ich mir doch dann auch irgendwas, irgendwas anderes holen zum Anschließen, ok, wir gucken
uns jetzt mal die Effekte an, wir gucken uns jetzt mal die Effekte an, ah, also, Effektchamp,
stell auf eine Farbe ein, ja, was wollen wir machen hier, zack, gelb, aber gelb, das ist
eine schöne Farbe hier, für so gemütliche Stimmung, das, ihr erkennt jetzt nicht, dass
es so richtig gelb ist, weil halt die Kamera versucht das weiß anzugleichen, ja, jetzt
denkt sie es ist rot, das ist gar nicht so, also die Farben sind, die Farben sind nicht
so wirklich echt hier im Stream, ja, so, ähm, gelbes Pock, genau, so, gucken wir uns mal
die Effekte an, also, Effekts, someone, Android, wow, ich mach mal so, dass man alles sieht,
da drehst, da wirst du ja verrückt im Kopf, wenn es da so lang läuft, da drehst du ja
durch bei, ok, blink, blink rainbow, ok, das überfordert die iPhone-Kamera, bouncing balls,
ok, also Leute, Epilepsie-Warnung, Epilepsie-Warnung, das ist ja nicht mehr normal hier, BPM, ha,
das kommt in der iPhone-Kamera nicht so gut rüber, aber, ähm, das läuft hier jetzt
so herzschlagmäßig, breathe, das wird ein bisschen heller, ein bisschen dunkler, das
ist ok, Candle, Candle flackert, dann gibt's Candle Mutti, ach ne, Candle Mutti, oh der
ist schön, der gefällt mir, das ist ein guter, das ist ein guter Effekt für den Weihnachtsbaum,
das ist gut, das gefällt mir, das ist nice, das ist so schön dezent, Moment Leute, ich
muss das richtige Emote nochmal schnell einbinden, sonst, sonst, das muss jetzt sein, das ist
ganz wichtig, äh, Keck, Keckmas, Keckmas, äh, Moment, wie heißt das Emote, was wir
haben, Keck, ach ne, Keck wie Christmas, Moment, ich brauche das richtige, ich brauche das
richtige Emote, ohne das Emote geht es jetzt nicht, da müsst ihr jetzt durch, das ist das
richtige Emote, das brauche ich, das da, und sonst nix, Keck W1, genau, Keck W1, genau
den, jetzt ist alles gut, jetzt können wir fortfahren, sehr gut, sehr gut, so, ok, ich
bin bereit, ich kann jetzt grad nicht im Discord gucken, so, Chase, ok, das flitzt, das flitzt
im Kreis, aber ordentlich flitzt das im Kreis, ja, das ist ganz nice, Chase, Flash, äh,
macht das was, ah, das wackelt manchmal an manchen LEDs ein bisschen, ok, na dann, Chase,
Flash, random, ne, also, Leute, ihr seht auf der Kamera so gut wie nix, ich seh auch so
gut wie nix, also das ist nix, äh, jetzt, unnormales, Skillkiller, Track and Drop, sagt
auch, Chase, oh, Copper Pride Mode, Copper Pride Mode, Activated, Chase Random, der ist
cool, der ist cool, der gefällt mir, das machen so die Kabel, so, Wärme, nichts, äh,
der ist cool, der gefällt mir, Chun Chun, oh, oh je, ok, das, ne, das hältst du nicht
lang aus, das ist ja fast schon Folter, sich das die ganze Zeit anzugucken, Zirkus, das
ist einfach nur weiß und rot, ok, colourful, das ist colourful, das ist bunt, Einsteiger,
Horst die Brose, kannst du dich irgendwie für, für, äh, Web-Anwendungen erwärmen,
dann würd ich dir zum Einstiegen HTML, JavaScript CSS empfehlen, einfach weil's motiviert,
wenn du siehst, was passiert, ansonsten, mein persönlicher Favorit ist ja nach wie
vor C-Sharp, Wishlist Studio gibt's kostenlos, und wenn du unter Linux bist, kannst du Wishlist
Studio Code verwenden, ähm, aber wahrscheinlich bist du unter Windows unterwegs, da ist C-Sharp
.NET und Wishlist Studio nicht verkehrt, und was da Stripes007 fragt, ist genau die richtige
Richtung, in welche Richtung soll's denn gehen, was willst du denn machen, Colour Loop, Leute,
ich glaube, das sieht besser aus, wenn ich Licht dazu anmache, jetzt, seht ihr die Farbe,
macht keinen Unterschied, ob ich das Licht an hab oder nicht, oder, ne, macht keinen
Unterschied, okay, das, ja, ich hatte das Licht angestellt, das hat man nicht gesehen,
das ist cool, das ist nice, leider kommt das auf der iPhone-Kamera nicht wirklich gut rüber,
das ist nice, Colour Waves, Juhu, Dancing Shadows, wow, ach du Scheiße, ne, ne, das halte ich
halt aus, Dissolve, äh, jetzt ist Licht an, und jetzt, aber jetzt geht's einfach aus,
ja, das ist ja langweilig, Dissolve RNG, da ist die Farbe einfach random, aber der Effekt
der gleiche, ne, das ist ja langweilig, Trip, da sind ganz viele Dinger, die übelst rumspinnen
und übelst rumspacken, aber ich glaube, das ist Absicht, das ist nicht, dass der ESP rumspackt,
das ist der Effekt, wie kann man eine Dateikröße in Hex-Value umwandeln, äh, naja, das ist
ein Bytes, das ist eigentlich schon in Hex, also Bytes sind, ja, bis, also Null, Null bis
F, oder, ach ne, du meinst die Anzeige in Windows, in, äh, die Dezimalanzeige, äh,
ja, dann musst du einfach diese Zahl, gib in Google ein, ähm, glaub, diese Zahl, Dez-2-Hex,
ich glaub, das kann Google sogar mittlerweile, Dynamic, das ist langweilig, das ist auch langweilig,
Fire, oh, der ist cool, der gefällt mir, der ist nice, der Effekt ist nice, wie gesagt,
das kommt jetzt auf der iPhone-Kamera nicht so richtig, nicht so, nicht so richtig gut,
das ist recht guter Feuereffekt, so von unten nach oben, der ist, der ist wirklich ganz,
ganz, ganz nett, also Horstie Pro, wenn du von irgendeinem Embedded-Gerät das machen
musst, dann, ähm, sieht das schon wieder anders aus, also sprich, wenn das irgendein
Micro-Controller ist, dann ist das ein ganz anderes Thema, das sind Fireworks, ich glaub,
der Effekt kommt einfach nicht so gut rüber, weil das hier so geschlängelt liegt, oh,
what the fuck, hey, das sieht wirklich ein bisschen aus wie, ey, das sieht wirklich
aus wie Feuerwerk, das ist ja nice, komm mal, für alle, die keinen Bock haben, Feuerwerk
zu machen, kauf ich einfach eine LED-Leiste, das sieht wirklich aus wie Feuerwerk, Firework
Starbust, ja, hey, das ist cool, Silvester Stream gesichert, ja, Flow, oh, der ist auch
nett, der ist schön angenehm, da blitzt ab und zu mal was, das, das sieht eher aus, als
sind die LEDs kaputt, Farbverlauf, oh, Halloween, hm, warum ist das Halloween, Halloween Eyes,
Hound KS, oh, das ist ein cooler Effekt, da blitzt immer sowas auf und fällt dann wieder
weg, Poggers, such mal ein Firework-Soundtrack, können wir dann zum Schluss mal mit allem
durchsehen, ich erinnere mich gleich noch mal dran, machen wir gleich zum Schluss, zum
Outro, Heartbeat, oh, zu anstrengend, EQ, ja, Lightning, oh, ist das Gewitter, oh, das
ist echt Gewitter, lol, das ist ja geil, das ist Fake Gewitter, alter, das ist Fake Gewitter,
das ist ja geil, ok, Loading, Merry Christmas, ja, ok, vielleicht, Kokona Christmas, Meteor,
ein weicher Meteor, ein Multikomet, ich erkenne da nichts, achso, doch, da, naja, das ist
Rauschen 1, Rauschen 2, Rauschen 3, Rauschen 4 und das freundliche Rauschen, oh, der ist
nett, der gefällt mir, welche Firma, WLED, Oscillate, Pazifia, Palette, ah, Faced, oh,
der gefällt mir, der ist nicht so hektisch wie der andere, der ist gut, der gefällt mir,
Faced Noise, ah, zu hektisch, die haben ja 30 Milliarden Effekte, Plasma, oh, oh, Anzeige
ist raus, Modus, Leute, Anzeige ist raus, Polizei sind informiert, gleich werdet ihr
abgeholt, Chat, gleich stehen sie bei euch vor der Tür, das sind Police, der hier war
besser, oh, Popcorn, oh, das ploppt aber ganz schön viel, das Popcorn, Pride, das ist gar
kein Regenbogen, ok, gleich haben wir das, Railway, Rain, ja, mit sehr viel Willen erkennt
man das als Regen, Rainbow, der ist auch ganz nett, nicht so hektisch, ok, der ist mir
zu hektisch wie der, Random Colors, na, was der macht, Red und Blue, Ripple, der ist auch
nett, der ist auch nicht ganz so hektisch, das ganze in Rainbow, Running, der ist auch
nett, zu hektisch, Saw, äh, warum, warum ist das Saw, Scan, ach, der ist auch ganz nett,
da läufts einmal, das ist auch nicht so ultra hektisch alles, jaja, hab ich schon gesehen,
machs gut, Elchenlenker, Saw, Scanner, Scanner Dual, oh, der ist nett, ich glaub die Kamera
ist, aber kann es sein, dass die Kamera gecrashed ist, die Kamera gecrashed, ja, die Kamera
ist gecrashed, das da, oh, ich geh jetzt, ich geh, oh, Alter, das hört ihr, ich geh
jetzt mal schnell durch, das dauert mir zu lang, Sparkle, Dark, Spot, was klingt noch
nicht, Sunrise, der ist hübsch, der gefällt mir, ja, oh ne, Traffic Light, ah, Grün,
und jetzt müsst ihr Orange und Rot werden, oder, irgendwann mal, Orange und Rot, ok,
2H7 Swipe, ok, was soll ich noch mal machen, Fireworks, ne, welches Fireworks war es noch
mal, so, ne, das da, ne, hier, ok, ok, ich mach die passende Untermalung, Achtung, Fireworks
Sound, das ist bestimmt mittlerweile auch alles Monka Tost, geht doch fast als original
durch, und das jetzt noch gesunken auf den Sound, na, das ist doch was, ne, man kann
das Sinken irgendwie, ja, aber das probier ich jetzt nicht mal aus, ok, Chat, oh ne, Chat,
ja, ok, also Leute, schön, dass ihr im Stream dabei wart, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen,
ich mach jetzt Schluss, also, wir sehen uns, und es war mal wieder schön, dass der Chat
auch richtig hilfreich war, nicht nur Pipega Chat, wie es sonst so auf Twitch ist, bei
mir ist halt, der einzig wahre, Rionic on Fire, ne, nur Fire, 2 Monate, Dankeschön
für den Sub, der Chat war tatsächlich hilfreich, ich hätte es auch nicht für möglich gehalten,
ich hab Bits bekommen, hab ich nicht gesehen, ich hab schon ein paar Subs übersehen, Horstie
Bros, 100, 100, 100, 4 Billionen Euro, Dankeschön, den hättest du aber wahrscheinlich eher
an Stripes geben müssen, aber trotzdem, danke für die Huge Tips, sorry, falls ich irgendwelche
Subs nicht gesehen hab heute, ich war ein bisschen beschäftigt, es kommt der Hype-Trendy, Hype-Trendy,
ne, der Hype-Trendy, den hypen wir jetzt nicht mehr, nicht ausgehyped-trained, Doktor
Meerschick, 3 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, ich schau ab, also, machts gut, wir sehen
uns bald wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.